there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody can everybody hear me yeah
okay because i have been [ __ ] around
with this thing today rejection who says
can you just say soft bounce i'm in the
[ __ ] dark well don't [ __ ] with that
too much because it'll fall off of here
it's like on a
okay it's on a clip
and i tried to move it before and it
fell off it won't go this way
i was just trying to get some of that
okay maybe
should i brighten it yeah brighten it
just a little bit okay let me see let me
get this
sorry technical difficulties
it's all new setup yeah this is uh
okay yeah better is that better okay i
think that's better
you guys like that lighting better
yeah i didn't realize because like i
said i called the the customer service
today and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
guys like you know been overrun by
zombies or why is your [ __ ] not working
and um
you know
he told me a couple things that i was
like okay i can do that but then he told
me a couple things i'm like yeah that's
not gonna work uh but i adjusted some
settings in obs and i updated obs and
what i didn't realize until i started
streaming was that the new version of
obs prior i had obs open over here and
then i had youtube open over there so i
had the chat like in youtube and now obs
does all of that within the program so i
don't actually have to have youtube open
in another window
i just couldn't find the chat window for
a long time and i'm sitting there going
where the f i can't see the chat sure i
think that's less load on the data
stream and i'm i hope so i'm totally off
of it uh we have we have hughes net
which is a satellite it's backup
satellite we still have that just in
case yeah so i'm on the backup satellite
internet so i'm off of
i'm off of the that data stream
totally it's slow as [ __ ] but i'm
getting um chats come on time
the uh
the visual i have is [ __ ] 144 p and
it's [ __ ] a couple seconds behind but
that doesn't matter we just look like a
bunch of pixels yeah probably because
i'm just looking at this at the at the
uh at the chats yeah but that's okay i
mean i don't want to like hype it up too
much because i'm just paranoid the data
stream looks
steady looks steady which
i don't know it did it does before too
and sometimes then like as you go under
that i'm just like paranoid you know it
seems to be that we have it set up more
efficiently though i hope so we'll see
because i don't entirely know what i'm
doing yeah but i tried to like watch
some videos today about it's like what
if i have i just want to do like i was
like what if you have like a really
shitty internet connection i mean arson
isn't shitty but it's just a little like
intermittent it seems like and so i was
just like okay what if you have a really
shitty one i'm gonna use those [ __ ]
settings yeah just in case so now
certain way you can just dim that just a
little bit
dim with the light that you just turned
on can you dim it just a little bit i
can well uh yeah yeah a little bit more
one more
yeah
i can make it also i can make it warmer
or cooler i think that looks good yeah
it's usually warmer looks better like if
you go the other way it goes like blue
it was too blue
i think that looks better no i got it on
the warmest setting yeah before oh okay
because i saw you drop that blue
i was looking here and that blue
blueness went away you got some [ __ ]
back there paulson yeah sure yeah
i can't figure out like how those lights
work okay i know how to do it well none
of the buttons uh seem to do anything
it does you push it and it's like i'm
like okay
there's like three or four buttons on
the back and none of them seem to do
they all scroll it's been a while since
i've messed with them each one is a
different category yeah i figured that
out but it's just it just really seems
to me i was just kind of like
this is too uh i was like i don't have
time for this i used to have that [ __ ]
set up on a damn light board and i it's
a cheap ass light board anyway and
[ __ ] it was all upon the damn daisy
chained all them lights together
and i couldn't get it to work that light
board that [ __ ] was so complicated i
said [ __ ] it we still have that light
board so i have it yeah it's in the
closet i'm like it wasn't really worth
it because i can set each one
independently yeah
the weird thing about it is that some of
those lights like we haven't plugged in
if you unplug them and then plug them
back in they'll retain their settings
sometimes
uh all of them did except for that one
which is now scrolling yeah i plugged
all the ones in and i'm like oh good
they got the same settings back so i
don't have to [ __ ] with it and then that
one though would just wanted to be a
rebel i guess and it just like would
know i'm just going to scroll through
all the colors and i'm just like all
right just be that way i think we're on
an ethernet cable huh we're on the
ethernet cable not anymore because it
wasn't i have an ethernet cable yeah and
i had it hooked up to the booster but
that was not working i was do i have
like three or four different connections
like with various things i got a booster
i got a 5g i got this that and the other
and i did a test with each connection
like on ucla like the speed test and the
5g
without the ethernet is still the
fastest
even though that's kind of the one that
kept with dropping it but i'm
i don't know i just i don't know i don't
know we don't know what it is nothing
[ __ ] works the way it's supposed to
and it makes me very very angry yeah um
but you know what i mean hopefully it'll
be all right it's the same one remember
that old remember that old laptop that
we bought
that we got rid of because a fan sent us
this one
yeah well
actually the one the fan set i think
you're using okay that's this one i
bought
target i thought it was the other way
around okay i think yes i think i bought
this one because that one was dropping
off but i wonder if it would i wonder if
i wonder if it works now
i wonder if it worked better now i have
no idea i'm not even willing to
this [ __ ] is so clutch together and
complicated i have no idea how to like
reset another thing up and uh it makes
me tired let me start
i know that people wanted me to stream
my own little thing yeah man well here's
the thing because it's pain in the ass
i'm telling you well one it's a pain in
the ass too if i were to stream and say
what i want to stay on on youtube they
kick me off well you don't have to be on
youtube there's tons of other streaming
platforms well i already looked at it
all right [ __ ] uh [ __ ] shoot
um doesn't have a live
stream yet all right the other one is
rumble rumble is good the problem with
rumble is that you have to pay a hundred
dollars a month to stream off a rumble
that's the thing about it [ __ ] that
noise yeah
yeah
i mean i'd probably make that in super
chat's back but
i don't know
you couldn't count you couldn't count on
that couldn't count on it right i want
to like anything that's going to like
charge you to stream
you don't need that rumble keeps the rip
riffraff off
they're early they're early in their
development and they just keep the
riffraff off by well if you want to
stream then you have you can spend 100
bucks a month
you know
and but they have super chat features
and [ __ ] but i'd get kicked off anything
other than all i'd have to be on all
tech
because you're always running your mouth
on my mouth while you also know
is i'd be i'd be talking about
military situations that i'd be doing
basically classes on certain types of
military type training or the
philosophies behind things a lot of it
would be about equipment and
man there's all this [ __ ] about guns
and everybody's got a show about guns so
it's like a
gun tube is good a lot of them are very
good but it's just saturated with that
and a lot of it's armchair commandos and
you know they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about really or they're
talking about the last few conflicts and
each conflict
is its own situation and don't they
usually don't repeat
every war has its own thing i mean [ __ ]
[ __ ]
chad was in a war with [ __ ]
the dudes from damn
mama gaddafi where was where was gaddafi
from he was from [ __ ] uh what country
was that i can't even remember now yeah
they were fighting [ __ ] with toyota
trucks against tanks and the trucks
[ __ ] beat the tanks
people would think well
t-72 tanks [ __ ] trucks toyota
fours
with guns on the back
sponsored by toyota toyota but yeah it's
sponsored by toyota not really kicked
ass on [ __ ] hundreds of [ __ ]
gaddafi's tanks i used to have a toyota
yeah it was a good so everything is just
depends on the situation you know
so said libya that's olivia that's right
olivia i was going to say that but i was
like well i don't want to be wrong and
sound like a dummy song
chad kicked libya's ass
with [ __ ] toyota trucks
with 20 millimeter cannons in the back
that
which is
a military would tell you that was
impossible but no
nothing's impossible if you've got
willpower and speed
well some things are still impossible
yes
yeah well actually you got to have a
good thinking
you know and if i could put a 20
millimeter cannon or 40 millimeter
cannon in the back of a [ __ ]
4x4 [ __ ] pickup truck and you can get
behind the [ __ ] tank real quick and
just blast it to pieces
you know militaries don't think that way
but civilians and rebels think do think
that way
but anyway if i got involved in [ __ ]
my own channel i'd be saying [ __ ] that
would piss a lot of people off they'd
[ __ ] kick me off of youtube
i wanted to uh give a shout out to
oracle uh she's having her surgery
tomorrow so he sends some good
vibes been on the
guest and friend of the show for [ __ ]
over a year yeah so
i hope everything goes okay i know how
scary that is uh and she's gonna make it
it'll be all right she's gonna make it
um and i wanna do a couple shout outs
too because before we get too far into
it
uh i did a couple of them on
the
show that we did about charles the
charles bronson movie but i didn't know
if any ever anybody was watching like
everybody was watching it so i wanted to
make sure that everybody like uh was
around for it so i wanted to say thanks
again to murder hornets for the little
skulls which go
can you get them back there they're
right back there by
the two little ones right it's the two
little ones so i wanted to show these
and they sent many of them over yeah
yeah yeah these are just like the newest
ones so uh so he just sent me those so i
wanted to like show them to everybody in
case you weren't here yesterday the day
before whenever i showed them they're
hand painted and they're super awesome
uh so thank you very much for that i
love that kind of stuff i love that kind
of stuff also
we got a box yesterday from chewie which
was addressed to pookie ashford
and
i'm not entirely sure who it's from um
somebody named ali sent me an email and
asked for the home address so it might
have been from her or it might have been
from for some reason i thought maybe it
was from tammy but i'm not entirely sure
but it was a whole box from chewie full
of those tuna meat sticks those sheba
ones that pookie loves him i don't even
want to say meat sticks out loud because
she might be like she's back here
looking at you
yeah because she knows that uh phrase
sometimes sometimes i try to like spell
it yeah um
just like she's just like a child she
knows how she knows certain words so i
have to spell them
uh but yeah so meat sticks is too sh
meat sticks is too long for me to spell
but yeah so thank you uh whoever sent us
she's like oh i'm gonna go over here
maybe i'm gonna get it
she's going over there like the thing
but yeah thank you very much for that
those tuna ones are her favorite and she
is just um
she's decided that that's all she's
gonna eat now pretty much she has a
teaspoon of wet food in the morning
which i think is chicken flavor
uh and she'll just eat meat sticks
pretty much she doesn't even really eat
that many of the uh temptations crunchy
things anymore she'll leave those like
to eat the meat sticks also i want to
give a uh shout out to miguel for
sending me a paypal donation
and he said you should use this to take
a day off and just go get yourself like
a cup of coffee and a muffin or
something like that and i was like a
facial
not that kind of thing i was getting
wait i was like what from you
not that kind of i don't want some
stranger jerking off on my face what are
you talking about
[ __ ] rub some avocado cream up into
your [ __ ] face i can do that at home
i'm not paying for that i got all kind
of masks and
and acids and oils and all that kind of
[ __ ] i'm gonna i can do that at home i'm
not paying for that but um just like i
don't pay to get my [ __ ] nails
painted yeah they kind of look like ass
but again it's too expensive i'm not
paying to do that it's like if i'm gonna
pay i said i told him i said maybe i'll
go to downtown sanford and get like some
nice german food for lunch and then go
poke around in the bookstore and buy a
big pile of books that sounds like a fun
day to me so i might do that this
weekend
who sent bobblehead dennis
i think sophie did
yeah yeah then sophie said sophie sent
dennis and then i think that no need for
me to if i'm not mistaken sent
the bobble head of h.h homes because we
also have an h.h holmes one uh from the
same line there's a whole serial killer
line i don't know how many there are now
they have like a cup they have a ted
bundy they have an ed gein in clown
makeup and without yeah uh i think they
have a richard ramirez it's kind of
[ __ ] up but you know that's weird
they're all good they are they are they
they they took a you know dennis's head
broke off but i fixed it yeah because
you dropped him yeah although it's like
you dropped him like on the carpet yeah
and his head just like broke right now
they weigh a lot they're baby they do
they're they are very heavy i mean
they're very they're very well it was
easy to fix it i had the right kind and
you can't see the you can't see the
repair it's underneath it's inside the
head
but it's underneath the bubbles it's
underneath the bottle
yeah just broke the stem off
we couldn't believe it it happened live
on the show do you remember that yeah
when you were doing the dentist and like
you kind of dropped him and it's like
it's like oh my god that bad ass chinese
glue that's not even supposed to be in
the country
yeah because yeah it probably gives you
cancer yeah that's why yeah that's that
[ __ ] there's a two part it smells
like it gives you cancer [ __ ] man i'm
gonna tell you that right you can glue
two pieces of metal together and it's
like oh it's better than jb weld it's
better than [ __ ] it's that's just a
bad ass and the motorcycle dealer who
sent it to me says don't tell anybody i
gave that to you i was like what but you
just did this is that's not really
supposed to be here yeah like oh okay
you're not good all right yeah yeah
just don't like drip any of it between
like your dick and your thigh or looking
at it too hard you'll get eye cancer
[Laughter]
you probably already got ideas from
looking at it yeah like i said it smells
like it would give you cancer but uh but
yeah so the show tonight i regret to
inform you it's gonna be kind of a
bummer and this is
this makes you feel kind of bad because
i'm not going to lie if you grew up in
the 1980s
um the whole
dingo ate my baby line which is not even
what she said she said a dingus got my
baby yeah but the whole like a dingo ate
my baby thing
became sort of like a pop culture it
became a meme essentially in the 80s uh
it was on i think they did [ __ ]
saturday live sketch on it they made
jokes about the simpsons i heard an mst
reference to it there's like there's
lots and lots even people nowadays that
weren't even [ __ ] alive when this
[ __ ] happened
no that line i think there's a band
called that i saw when i did uh when i
was searching for sources to like
research it i saw like a it looked like
a soccer jersey and it was a number
eight so the number eight was really big
and then it said a dingo ate my baby
yeah and i was like funny but [ __ ] up
because
a dingo actually did eat a baby and like
think how [ __ ] horrible that would be
not only is it horrible that that
happened
but then the ensuing
let's call it a miscarriage of justice
that happens subsequently
where
i mean we'll get into that but
it's just like really really sad and now
i kind of feel bad that it became like a
joke because can you imagine
if your kid
a baby she was nine weeks old
got eaten by an animal and then everyone
thought it was hilarious
can you imagine how that would make you
feel i mean who thought it was they
thought it was hilarious well everybody
kind of made a joke about and honestly i
don't think it was so much
maybe in austria because it was like a
massive deal in australia obviously it
was like a big media sensation i don't
think it became
like meme worthy until the movie with
meryl streep came out a cry in the dark
um which in australia and new zealand is
called evil angels because that's what
the book was called that it was based on
but everywhere else is called the cry in
the dark and she got like an oscar
nomination for that
and you know her doing the australian
accent and her saying that in the movie
apparently that just like struck like
people as funny for whatever reason
so
it became kind of like
a joke which is terrible it's kind of
terrible the only thing i can say about
this case
at least
this baby died right
uh this baby died but at least this was
not something done out of malice this
wasn't an evil person that came and did
this to try to hurt anybody this is an
animal just trying to get something to
eat they didn't can't tell one kind of
baby for another it's like food
yeah at least it wasn't it's a tragedy
but it wasn't it wasn't a crime but the
weird thing about that and i'm glad you
brought that up because
because conversely
i feel like
the fact that uh the dingo most likely
did take the baby and eat the baby
um but then subsequently the mom was
blamed for murdering the baby and it was
like like i said it was a whole thing
she did jail time and everything
i kind of feel like maybe a lot of the
reason behind
people thinking that she did it and
coming up with like all these [ __ ]
crazy ass uh justifications for that
is because it's almost like the opposite
of what you said i think people feel
better
when there is a person that they can
blame and punish for something
because
if
a dingo
took somebody or a dog or whatever like
took your baby and ate the baby
um
you know and that happened then that
means that could happen to you and
nobody wants to think that random [ __ ]
like that could happen to them so
they're like no somebody must have done
this right into some intelligent person
like out of malice like you said in a
weird in a [ __ ] up way i think that
makes some certain types of people feel
better because that means oh that's not
going to happen to me because if it's
just random then that's where that's
where witch hunts come from oh yeah
something that happened so we got to
blame somebody
yeah and it goes on to this day
yeah it's very human and it's not all
humans because not all humans have that
but some like particular types of humans
do
want somebody intelligent behind
something and like i said well i've
talked about this before this is the
thing that's behind conspiracy theories
it's behind all this kind of stuff you
need a person to blame and crazily
enough you see this a lot
when
uh something happens to a little kid
like if a little kid is kidnapped or
murdered or something like that
most people and i'm not saying that it's
not unheard of for like the parents to
be involved because sometimes they are
um you know most murders of people it's
usually by people they know and a lot of
times when kids are murdered yes it is
not necessarily their parents but family
members or someone they know like a
neighbor or something like that so
that's not like crazy to think that you
hear that
what yeah it was some what was it
was it thunder or did somebody hit
something
i can't tell like our neighbors are
saying longer oh okay
yeah i did see it's so hopefully like
the weather isn't going to interfere
because i did see like rain streams been
going solid
i mean
so far like i said
we'll see yeah but this kind of reminds
me of uh hurricane katrina hurricane
katrina hit
[ __ ] caused devastation it was like
the [ __ ] apocalypse man
and they had to blame somebody they were
trying to blame anybody for [ __ ]
katrina they were blaming people well
though you know people broke down the
[ __ ] the the dykes or the levees and
[ __ ]
you know who was [ __ ] guilty for
[ __ ] katrina anybody who lived in new
orleans was [ __ ] guilty
you were all guilty i mean not guilty
just for [ __ ] living there well yeah
but i mean damn bold but bad [ __ ] could
happen to you anywhere you live to be
fair yeah but [ __ ] new orleans is a
damn bowl okay built on
built out rotten [ __ ] bales of cotton
and uh [ __ ] it was only a matter of
time for [ __ ] massive flooding that
[ __ ] was overdue for [ __ ] decades
dumb to live in new orleans wells was
not supposed to be there well like i
said you can't really blame people for
living because one maybe they can't
afford it they're born there maybe
they're born there and they can't afford
to move but the thing is it's just like
people from like california it's like
there's like oh well there's earthquakes
and it's like your house could fall on
you but it's it's normalcy bias
normally new orleans is all right
okay but new orleans a disaster waiting
to [ __ ] happen all right it's too
goddamn low
and it's surrounded by marshes and
[ __ ] the ocean it's just well you
could say the same thing about people
that live in coastal areas in florida
because we get hurricanes too yep and
flash flooding and tidal waves and all
that kind of we get the same kind of
[ __ ] yeah but it's not built on
it's not [ __ ] built with [ __ ]
levees and [ __ ] all around to keep the
water out of it i mean it's just
it's worse it's much worse in new
orleans it was not supposed to be there
it was a pirate village
that's what it was from the 1500s
yeah but you know so they just couldn't
leave that place what we're saying uh
you know it seems like we got a little
bit off from that but not really because
i do kind of feel like a lot of the
backlash against
interestingly the backlash almost all
against the mom not necessarily the dad
even though spoiler alert he got some
prison time too as accessory after the
fact
but they almost always blame the mom in
these kind of situations uh for whatever
reason draw your own conclusions
there but
i'm just saying that for a certain type
of people not for everybody but for a
certain type of people they would rather
believe
that a woman would
you know would kill their own baby and
then say you know a dingo ate it then
actually have like a dinghy i'm like
it's a wild animal animals do eat [ __ ]
like i said a couple years back we had
that [ __ ] right here in disney
in one of those
like an alligator ate a little kid
yeah he was too close to the side of the
thing
it happens tina just showed up
it sucks it's horrible i couldn't
imagine what that would be like if that
happened to your kid but blaming a
person is not gonna like solve anything
because it wasn't a person that caused
it to shut up i gotta put my eyepatch on
i know what this does to that woman
gotta entertain i'm entertaining you
taylor i got my eye patch off
there you go
yeah um let's see uh yeah terry says i'm
from australia uh i think it's so unfair
yeah i mean i can't imagine having your
baby
die in that horrifying way and then
have everybody and still to this day
i think as far as that i'm not sure when
the last poll was but it wasn't that
long ago
about 52 percent of australians still
believe that she killed the baby that's
good savages even australian people are
savages shame on you
like where any better
i don't even know what happened i wasn't
there that's what i mean well to see you
should like [ __ ] listen to the [ __ ] i
don't know ham i wasn't there but you'll
probably never know but it's but a dog a
dingo could eat a baby alligators eat
babies all the time they eat [ __ ]
children
they've been eating children in the
south for [ __ ] centuries
that's what i mean it's just i don't
know it's it [ __ ] kills me so
yeah i'm just saying that
there are old southern postcards and
memes showing little black children
trying to run from the alligators
because it was an old meme that
alligators just ate up all the black
children
yeah and it's crushed out look it up
and it's true though
i know but it's like that's not funny to
like sell [ __ ] postcards of it like
look how [ __ ] funny this is
alligator's killing little black babies
yeah so anyway
it was a meme you know what i mean
we need an asteroid to come because it's
the earth to be honest with you we're
the worst yeah but
black people in that era lived up in
areas where near the water but so do
poor white people
and uh
alligators that go up meet the children
i mean they ate children of any color
but well yeah alligator doesn't know the
difference they're just like hey meat no
but evidently back in the very old south
in the very early 1900s
the meme was that they mostly ate the
black children
so they started putting but see that
might have been a variation of that
because it's like oh alligators only eat
black kids so they won't eat my kids so
they have photographs that's why you can
see this a lot of a lot of this is
[ __ ] from you know louisiana
and uh the new orleans area around
uh because there wasn't any that's going
on mississippi but you just see they
just stage a photograph they'd have some
black children up on top of a damn
log sticking up out of the water and
they'd superimpose some damn
alligators trying to eat them and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
or they'd [ __ ] get a black dude to
[ __ ] jump down inside a dead
alligator's mouth and they take a
picture of him and he's trying to fight
his way out of alligator it's just
[ __ ] it's like there's a [ __ ]
sense of humor back there
i'm all for dark humor i am yeah but
come on yeah they're [ __ ]
that's too far even for me [ __ ]
were rude
yeah yeah that's like that's that's not
cool that's not cool not at all uh tyler
says ever seen waking freight you know
what um i was just thinking about that
movie a couple days ago and that's one
that's been on my list that i've been
wanting to see for like a long time i
think it's actually on shutter so i will
probably get around to it uh very soon
yeah terry said people still spit on her
damn that's ridiculous to be honest i
mean she's married to an american now
and um but they moved back to australia
if i was her i think i would like change
my name and get the [ __ ] out i mean she
shouldn't have to
because she didn't do anything tila said
hey booze she's calling us the booze
i'm looking awesome with the eye patch
thank you very much to you i put this
ipod on especially for you
and then you put your glasses over it
which kind of ruins the effects tell
your big husband i say hi
all right
and then she what she talked about
australia
that she is i don't feel bad about the
alligator that i ate in front now i
don't feel bad about the alligator he
ate in in new orleans honestly i wish
alligators tasted better they don't
taste that good i mean they're okay yeah
but
you know it's look i don't you know a
little flaky a little bit dry
i like animals and i don't really like
cruelty animals but alligators and
crocodiles are [ __ ] scary man
i know they don't know any better
they're just going to eat you because
like i said they're just like hey meat
meat's there so i'm going to eat it but
i'm going to say i think that's probably
why this case resonates with me a lot
and why it like bums me out so much is
because
me um i can't really think i mean i
could think of a lot of shitty ways to
die you know because i'm imaginative
like that but honestly one of the ways i
do not want to go is being eaten by an
animal yeah a crocodile or a shark or
even a mountain lion that i mean that
would suck a lot these alligators around
here are still eating children one of
them ate a child just a couple years
back right outside right there on the
[ __ ] on disney that's right i just
mentioned that yeah and i think that kid
was like a toddler i think he was two or
three two or three ran down there by the
water and that [ __ ] outlet well got
him
yeah parents took him to disney and
alligator got him that was on disney
grounds can you i would never get over
that i'm sorry yeah i just never would
that's that's [ __ ] can't trust him
that's [ __ ] horrible that's why
that's why jenny was always worried
about pookie leaving the [ __ ] house
and going down to the little pond
yeah rightfully so you you kind of acted
like i was like overreacting i'm like
absolutely not i checked the pond there
was no alligators in the pond well look
okay so a little while back after we
moved to this house yeah there's not
really any ponds i mean there are every
day i mean there aren't any ponds like
close enough and the yard is like kind
of big and there's other houses i mean
there are ponds but they're not like
really close like at the old house
but i mean pookie thankfully just really
seems to have lost all interest in going
outside pretty much she saw that dog
it's because there's two yeah it's
because of the dog at the old house and
there's two dogs next door in the fence
and she sees them and she's like [ __ ]
that noise and she comes back inside
which is fine with me now beijing does
occasionally slip out
uh one night she had gotten out and we
heard a noise that sounded like a cat
yelling
and then we couldn't find beijing for a
long time for like an hour to like we
were like going all over the
neighborhood and we thought
something got her like an owl or a bear
or a
wild cat or something and we were
freaking out and then
later she came back thank [ __ ] but
for a while there i was just kind of
like i don't think the cat should go
outside it's like i don't really
yeah and especially out here it's like
there's just too many fights florida
there's too many [ __ ] animals yeah
you gotta check if peop people might
wonder how the hell would i know if
there was an alligator in the pond it's
very easy
uh alligators move from one pond to the
next
um and once they get into a pond they
handle their business and if there's no
fish in there there's no food they'll
move to the next pond
but what you do is you go out there at
night
with a flashlight
and you just scan the pond if you don't
see any glowing eyes up on the surface
there's no alligator
because
alligators
will have their eyes above the surface
of the world in their nose and their
nose
yeah during
their little during the night time
they're holes they're up in the surface
they don't think anybody can see them
you know
so you can real quick with a lot with a
flashlight at night shine it on on the
pond and you don't see any eyes that are
not in there
every day they'll be on the bottom you
won't see them sometimes i mean the pond
that was by our old house was like prob
technically probably too small for an
alligator to live in but they'll visit
it i mean they could probably visit it
even though it was pretty little yeah
but i didn't really like so i'm just i'm
glad
in a way like it freaked me out that
that dog at the old house like scared
pookie so bad the dog didn't hurt her
the dog wanted to be friends with her
but he was like hey little kitty and she
was like [ __ ] that and she like ran away
and freaked out and like she hurt her
foot
um and after that she's like i don't
want to go outside anymore yeah which is
fine with me she can stay inside i don't
i don't like her being outside
especially not around here because i
don't know what the [ __ ] kind of animals
are wandering around there's all kind of
bears and all kind of [ __ ] and i don't
like it
uh james knapp says the big cat killing
you would be quick they hit the throat
and you'd be passed out i mean i would
hope so
but i don't know just that couple of
seconds of like knowing i'm about to be
eaten by a [ __ ] animal
man that would blow
that's why i can't like you know you
know grizzly man
that documentary
uh about the guy and his girlfriend that
got eaten by the bear like he was
hanging out with the bears um i listened
to that audio one time
never again i can't [ __ ] unhear that
that's [ __ ] horrifying yeah tyler
says it'll make florida sound horrible
or it sounds sound was it terrifying
um i'm not terrified by any of that it's
just you i mean i grew up you just kind
of have to like mitigate yeah
you know most of the time you walk
around and it's fine there's bears here
but there's bears there's there's
alligators there's crocodiles but you
don't see them that much crocodile is
mostly a south florida thing um you
don't really see them in the wild here
other i mean in the wild they're in the
everglades but that's like way south of
here there's sharks there's arapaima
yeah there's sharks uh barracuda yeah
there's all it's all kind of poisonous
there's angles
eagles [ __ ] out big ass owls big owls
yeah um you know and we're not wildcat
in the woods panthers i was just we just
left the suburb of sanford
and i've had bears [ __ ] stick their
[ __ ] noses in while i was working on
the bike and just walk around in suburbs
trying to get in people's refrigerators
they're black bears we're in a place
called black bear reserve we're on the
edge of orlando now
way on the edge
we're pretty much well we're like 20
something miles from downtown orlando
yeah
yeah but if you look at the suburban
sprawl we're on the edge of the sprawl
yeah
and uh oh man there's all kinds of but
even inside in suburbia there's black
bears
yeah
bears are not dangerous they'll root
through your garbage yeah or like i said
if you leave your garage door open
they'll come in there and root through
your fridge or maybe come in your house
and root through your fridge
but they can open a refrigerator
black bears have killed a lot of people
because they're so common so
statistically it's going to happen but
those are bad black bears most black
bears are no trouble
they're mostly just scavengers
they hang out in human areas because we
put out trash and the trash smells good
and smells like food they're very much
you can read their body language your
body language is a lot like a dog
they're
they're they're not looking for trouble
most of them they'll do a bunch of
bluffing
but they can get big
we've driven home and have one sitting
in a damn driveway the biggest chewbacca
sitting up on his back bigger i think it
was bigger well wider for sure
he was awesome he was really [ __ ] man
here he walked off
but they're not confrontational which
was fine i mean you know i was probably
you know to be fair i was probably like
a little drunk because we were coming
home from the club but
i was like wow look at that but i wasn't
i was a little bit scared but not really
because he didn't look threatening he
was just kind of sitting there in the
driveway being like ah [ __ ] well you can
tell right now just kind of lumbering
yeah like you can tell right from their
body language what kind of what kind of
person you're dealing with and they are
people like
they're a lot more intelligent than a
dog
more like a chimp but with a different
but the dog's personality
they can open a door they remember
everything they'll try to get into a
house
they're really cute though yeah yeah
they're like hey you got any food i
think they're kind of i know you got
food
if you feed them they'll start coming
and they'll bring their friends
that's weird they're having a bear
network yeah
well it's just kind of like the sandhill
cranes yeah that's why they tell you not
to feed them because then they'll like
then like other little families be like
hey we heard you had bread and granola
yeah so here we are they've had old
ladies that they had to basically kind
of find and threaten with
jail time because all they do is feed
bears and
every night she's got 20 or 30 bears out
there she's trying to feed [ __ ] dog
chow
watermelons and [ __ ]
feeding the bears and
she'll be out there [ __ ] they've got
it on video she's out there talking to
the bears and petting them and they're
like
don't touch me
some of them like to be petted some of
them don't you know well they're just
like people yeah thank you james hi
there jenny and tom showing support for
jenny this time watch wartime stories on
youtube what did you think about them i
don't know i don't see it
i don't know i don't know you might like
it i don't know i never heard maybe
i mostly watch uh horror [ __ ] and true
crime [ __ ] and
people uh
shopping for ten dollars a week at
dollar tree and cooking for a week yeah
i don't know why i'm so obsessed with
that but there's all kinds of stuff you
know a lot of world war ii stuff i'd
watch uh vietnam type stuff you know i'm
talking about
like units that i was in and what they
did in vietnam and second world war but
like i said
some of that stuff that happened these
little lessons that you learn you know
do apply
if you read history you'll take little
lessons from it that you can apply later
in future wars if you have to take place
and i'm getting kind of old for that but
[ __ ] this is
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] that's been going
on now man it's going to come back on us
all right it's just how it is
and um
we'll see but somebody was asking what i
thought of the if i'd given my opinion
on
what's happening now in ukraine and [ __ ]
um jenny doesn't really like me talking
about this kind of stuff but uh that was
decided a long time ago and that shit's
over
there as soon as they got as soon as
they got the ukrainians trapped in that
little pocket that's a wrap all right
[ __ ]
there's a bunch of propaganda you know
about oh man the russians are making so
much trouble oh they're slowing down
[ __ ] those [ __ ] did a great ass
mission and they won they're in a good
ukrainians are [ __ ] negotiating now
which
that means that they lost and it's not
going to be an occupation they just want
a neutral ukraine they'll probably be a
little neutral zone there
and uh they
they uh
you know it's gonna it's gonna work out
all right but here in the media here
they're gonna [ __ ] scream bloody
murder because our rich people who are
in politics invested in that place when
it comes to making drugs and sex slaves
and the weird [ __ ] that they do that's
their version of the atm all that will
come out
russian russia is getting a bunch of
evidence of what what what our rich
people are doing over there some of them
admit admit to it and they're going to
give that evidence to china and china is
going to take that before the u.n and
they're going to make the united states
look like look like a bunch of war
criminals
that's what's going to happen
just giving you the heads up
russia won that one and they're going to
vilify us and the world will believe it
a bunch of [ __ ] is going to come out
can we talk about the actual topic
tyler says i was actually born in
florida but i haven't been back since
infancy maybe there's an alternate
timeline where i stayed and i'm mostly
unfazed by it like you guys i don't i'm
not unfazed by it i was born here too
but um
i'm not unphased by it
you just have to most of the time you
don't
see the [ __ ] but
you see it often enough that you're just
kind of like oh look at that there's a
bear or oh look at that there's a
rattlesnake or something like that but
it is something that you have to think
about it's just like if you live in the
desert and you have pets you got to
worry about you know animals out in the
desert same thing uh so you have to
worry about snakes and bears and [ __ ]
like that here as well uh sharks
alligators and stuff
so yeah so somebody said like terry who
is from australia
uh was also saying imagine
this is what bothers me about this case
like i said it's shitty enough because
like i said one of my
worst nightmares
is being eaten
by an animal that's really that's right
up there on ways i do not want to die
uh
right there with plane crash and falling
several stories from a building i think
it's it's top three
being eaten by an animal bigger than me
is right up there
so being eaten by an animal that sucks
and then
the [ __ ] is like compounded
because can you imagine your kid getting
eaten by an animal and then everybody
thinking that you did it and calling you
a witch and saying you're in a cult and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
i can't even imagine like i said i would
just want to [ __ ] take a rocket and
get off this [ __ ] planet because how
i don't understand how you would even
deal with that and like [ __ ] good for
her
uh for hanging in there but
i don't know how she [ __ ] dealt with
it she must have had a like i said i
would have changed my name and got a
[ __ ] facelift and [ __ ] like that
i don't know and
just tried to start a new life nope
where nobody knew where i was
so uh so yeah are we ready to like talk
about the [ __ ] now because
we're like 45 minutes in i'll go ahead
so it shouldn't be that long of a case
huh uh well there's a lot of well you
don't
you don't really know that much about it
right so there's no there's kind of a
lot but there's a lot of stuff that that
happened in the in aftermath and i kind
of did want to go into like
both sides of the thing even though
honestly like i said i'm pretty sure
that it happened just the way she said
it happened but there was so much
it was one of those cases that i kind of
feel like she was i don't want to blame
the media entirely because a lot of the
authorities also wanted to nail her
and kind of
i don't want to say they finagled the
evidence in that direction
but
they did kind of like seemed like they
only looked for what they wanted to see
type of situation allegedly
yeah don't assume
but yeah so
this happened uh like i said if you guys
don't know uh this happened in 1980
and uh
happened at what is probably still best
known as ayers rock although uh it's you
know it's actually called uluru uh that
the big ass rock in the northern
territory in australia
so august 1980 the chamberlain family
uh they were from northern queensland
and they went on a camping trip to
uh to uluru they were gonna like you
know camp there in a tent there was a
bunch of other tourists there as well
have barbecues climb on the [ __ ] you
know it's it's a big [ __ ] uh you know
landmark so a lot of people go there to
see it
uh now at this point in time and this
will come into play uh as the story goes
on michael chamberlain who is the baby's
father
uh was a
uh minister in the seventh day adventist
church now i don't want to get too much
into the seventh-day adventists because
we talked about them a lot on our uh dr
kellogg show he was also a seventh-day
adventist it's an offshoot of
christianity they're a little weird but
um i mean from my point of view no
weirder than regular christians it's all
weird to me but whatever
um yeah but they uh
but the fact that they were seventh-day
adventists
um
maybe was part of the reason why they
were persecuted to an extent because
people
at that time
kind of thought that seventh-day
adventism was kind of culty
which i guess it does have culty aspects
but like i said i can't really speak to
that because it's all weird to me but
whatever um so there was that
so he was a minister
now uh
him and his wife lindy had been married
for 10 years
now as i said they were going on this
camping trip and it wasn't just that uh
azaria who was the baby she was nine
weeks old
and they also had two other kids uh two
boys aiden who was six and reagan who
was four
so they get there late at night on
august 16th at the campground and like i
said they weren't the only ones there
was a [ __ ] ton of other people there too
because it was a very popular
camping spot a very popular hiking spot
so the next morning august 17th
um michael the dad and the two sons
they started like hiking and climbing
around the rock and stuff whereas lindy
the mom uh obviously she has this baby
who's still very very young only nine
weeks old and they started doing going
around this uh cave like at the site
now she reported later and i don't have
any reason to doubt her
that while they were out uh kind of
poking around in the caves and stuff she
did actually see a dingo
looking at her um there had been some
reports of i mean this was a campground
dingoes are wild animals um they're
gonna hang around somewhere where they
think that there's food
uh bears do the same thing at
campgrounds in the united states because
you know campers come there they have
food you can kind of like hang around
the camp people are asleep you can steal
their food so i kind of feel like the
same thing was going on here so dingos
were kind of like hanging around in the
area and she uh said that she saw one
you know on that morning while they were
uh you know kind of poking around the
rock or the cave or whatever
so
after dark uh the family they kind of uh
get around there's like a little
barbecue thing
and they started like hanging around the
barbecues near where their tent was now
the tent is was very small i've seen
pictures of it with the two kids so the
two little boys like standing in front
of it so it's like a really really small
tent i don't even know if the whole
family would have fit in there to be
honest but i'm sure they did but they
all kind of had to probably be like
right like that
so um
lindy the mom she's like uh hanging out
there by the fire by the camp by the
barbecue with the baby in her arms
and uh her and her husband were talking
to this other couple that were also
camping there who were named greg and
sally lowe
and they also had a baby so they had
something in common
now around eight o'clock p.m sally uh
from the other couple
she actually had some garbage and she
walked over to like a garbage can and
she was gonna throw this stuff out
and she reported later that there was a
dingo that was like following her like
only a couple steps behind because she
had garbage and apparently it smelled
good it's like smelled like food
um so she was kind of like nervous about
that
a couple minutes after that michael
azaria's dad
actually started like throwing food like
bread and stuff like that to a dingo
that kind of came up to the campsite
bad idea this is why they tell like
don't feed [ __ ] wild animals at your
goddamn camp site i mean i feel like
that's camping 101 but okay well i used
to do it all the time but it was
squirrels
well squirrels aren't going to eat you
are they squirrels and squirrels and
raccoons
well yeah raccoons not going to eat you
either
i'm just saying if a bear wanders up or
a wolf or something hey have some meat
it's not like they can distinguish
between that and you
if a bear is begging it's because other
people have fed that bear
the problem with feeding a bear is that
is not so much that they'll eat you or
anything so you won't be they're big
they're man-sized
and you won't ever get rid of that
[ __ ] and if you don't give him
if you don't give him some bacon or
something he's gonna pop you upside the
head well a lot of times they'll come in
the house and that too they're like well
he's not giving me what he gave me
yesterday
and what an [ __ ] yeah
he's been nice to me so that so it must
be that he didn't bring it out it must
be in there i'm gonna go in there and
get it i'll save him the trouble
and they'll come into your house which
is probably about what they're what
their thought process is yeah because
they because they've gotten people have
walked into their kitchen and seen bears
laying on their ass with the
refrigerator open and all the food
scattered out eating hey man what's up
and they don't even think to run away
because they don't think they've done
anything wrong i didn't yeah i feel like
they don't think they've done they're
like hey hey what's up i'm eating i'm
eating your food come here come get some
they don't think it's all like i said
this is why you don't feed wildlife come
on in the water's fine you know they
don't have any concept yeah they don't
have any concepts this is your [ __ ] and
this is my [ __ ] they got their own
concept of money
yeah if you gave them something before
yeah so they virgo you will give them
something again that's right and if
you're not then there must be some issue
there's an issue so
you have to resolve that issue right
it's not stupid they're not going to
make it busy for you he will go in there
and get it for you he's like oh well he
must have just forgot he forgot yeah
i'll just go in there yeah i don't want
to buy you got to look at it from that
point of view yes they don't mean
anything that's just how that's just
their thoughts that's the way those
sandhill cranes had me trained yeah be
sitting there watching video games and
[ __ ] jump out of my skin somebody
knocking on the damn window yeah
i open it up in the [ __ ] all about
seven or eight cranes looking at you
with that red eye going hey we're here
feeding time their eyes not red it's
just there's a ring of red feathers
they're like we're here i know you
forgot but we're just telling them they
look at you like that go get that food
yeah it's like yeah
we just we've been standing here for
like 15 minutes i don't know why you
know i had to untrain them i'm getting a
water hose and spraying that and they
just sit there like this with their
wings open
they're like oh we're getting a bath all
right yeah that's nice that's a nice
feature you don't want to hurt them so
you know
they're protected bird
yeah yeah but they tell you i mean if
you had got coffee
yeah if you got caught by the hoa you
got it you got fined yeah they tell you
if they tell you specifically please do
not feast they get aggressive
well they're aggressive they're noisy
yeah i mean if you've never heard a
sandhill crane
call
they're very very loud
and um also they're very big and they
poop all over everything and they're
smart and they're very smart and they
show up with their children
here feed this one yeah that's the
weirdest thing the parents will stand
back there and push the children forward
feed that one give the baby something
yeah
[ __ ] it is hilarious though yeah i
get soft-heartedly okay i'm gonna give
them i mean it's hard not to because
they are kind of they are cute
i mean they're big and they're kind of
like scary
yeah they come up to your shoulder and
then you give them some bread you know
and they're like okay that's it go go
now go go okay okay we'll be back
tomorrow
we'll be knocking on your window
like [ __ ] big ass long beach they
could really probably [ __ ] you up if
they wanted to sure i mean that beak
they can put your eyes out easy pookie
was fascinated
yeah pookie-like she was like she was
like scared of them kind of but then
she'd like kind of get close she'd like
scooch closer in the grass yeah because
she'd scooch down the grass so they
couldn't see her even though they still
could but she thought they couldn't see
her and then like when the birds would
go up like that with their big ass
because they're really big you guys
they're condors yeah they're very big
and when they would do that she'd be
like oh
yeah it was like super funny but she
wouldn't run she just like thought they
were like super fascinating yeah they
thought that that was my baby
[Laughter]
she is yeah
funny [ __ ] animals
yeah well like i said i never like to
i don't i don't like to just presume
that the animal doesn't know what's
going on yeah i i relate to an animal
even a wild animal
as though it's a person
because i kind of well we evolve from
the same [ __ ] so we can't be that far
off you know what i'm saying as far as
body language and that kind of stuff
goes
they kind of they understand
yeah they understand tones of voice they
understand stuff like that straw dog
lives in a cheap apartment in south
florida it's being invaded by geckos of
centipedes
i used to have a pet gecko actually
granthar said one time i went camping in
yellowstone with the girl i was hanging
with when we crawled in the tent she
told me she was menstruating uh oh i
didn't sleep all night grizzlies are
attracted to such yeah you gotta watch
well actually they'll even tell you that
like if you're
uh you know girls that are out like on
camping trips or anything like that they
said if you got your period you got to
watch because
uh bears can smell that [ __ ] and they'll
like come after you yeah
dogs can't see you it's evident gorillas
can't yep dogs can't too it
says that the the the cranes bring the
young to me for child support
[Laughter]
yeah they do they think they're claiming
me is the daddy
and i'm asking for a [ __ ] test
[Laughter]
you're going to go on jerry springer
with a family of sand hill cranes yes
they're all sitting over there in the
chairs like looking at you with the red
feather eyes to prove that i'm innocent
that are you the daddy i am not the
daddy
oh my god now i know somebody needs to
make that something that's better at
video editing than me i really need to
make that i can picture the sandhill
cranes sitting in the chairs on the
jerry springer stage looking at you with
scans
these yeah children's everywhere with
the little baby ones yeah look the
little baby ones actually they grow
pretty fast i've seen like the baby baby
ones yeah because there was a family of
them that lived by the print shop where
i used to work babe ones are as tall as
the chicken about a foot tall yeah
they're about chicken size and then
they're yellow but they grow like really
fast like later they're in a couple
weeks they're almost the same size as
the parents the only way that you can
tell that they're still juveniles is
they don't have that red
they don't have that red feather around
their eyes yeah and they still have a
little bit of like that down underneath
their wings and they treat it like a
baby
yeah
they always travel in family groups yeah
little family they travel in pairs yeah
or two pairs
or
or a family like a pair and one or two
children the adults will eat out of your
hand yes they're old they're old hat
they trust you the babies well every
time they'll take it out of your hand
they jump and flutter like they just did
something
dangerous
it takes them a while to get to to trust
you
they'll take that hand
off and run
and then they come back and do it
together
it's like some big drama for them yeah
well they don't know maybe other humans
have smacked them around or something i
think it's just instinct every one of
them did that and the parents just sit
there well if i was a wild animal i
would also be like afraid of humans
they're scared like i said humans kind
of suck but most humans wouldn't hurt
them but they don't know that those
they're being fed by all kinds of people
i wasn't the only one feeding them
that's what i'm saying so it might be
some like weird psycho out there that's
like i'm gonna feed these birds i'm
gonna like pop them in the face or some
[ __ ] like you don't i don't think that's
what it is it's just instinct they know
you're not a bird
yeah and parents like go ahead go ahead
take it he's okay
we've eaten from him before and we
didn't die so it was okay yeah that's
like their poison testers yeah
but yeah so uh so what were we talking
about um yeah so michael the dad i'm not
i don't want to blame the parents or
anything like that because this could
happen to anybody but i'm i am going to
say
not a great idea if you're at a campsite
where there are wild animals around like
dingoes
probably not a good idea to feed them
i'm not saying that he did that on
purpose i'm not just saying he probably
just did it to amuse his children or
whatever but i'm just saying it's
generally not a good idea so just saying
that but uh he did actually feed the
dingo and uh the mom lindy was like uh
yeah like don't do that the voice of
reason
and um apparently the dingo then
according to
several people that were present
uh then pounced on a mouse that uh had
been running around the campsite
so there was that
uh so at this point lindy the mom
she says uh you know time to put the
baby to bed because it was getting to be
eight eight thirty nine o'clock uh
baby's bedtime
so uh goes into the tent and puts uh the
baby to bed i think there was either i
think there was like a little bassinet
in there or she had like something set
up for the baby you know like her little
crib or something
so she puts her in there she's in there
for maybe five ten minutes something
like like not a huge amount of time
so uh reagan the other kid who was four
uh was also asleep in the tent or was at
least had been put down for the name
so at that point lindy comes back to
the bench by the barbecue and everybody
else saw her
and then apparently only a few minutes
after that
uh pretty much everybody around the
campsite said they heard a baby's cry
that sounded very distressed and that
was like cut short
uh so lindy obviously um
runs back to the tent to see what's
going on
and then comes back and she's yelling
and the quote is i know everybody says
dango at my baby what she said was my
god my god the dingoes got my baby now
some of the sources that i saw said that
she
reported that she thought that she saw
she wasn't entirely sure because it was
dark out
she thought she saw like the ass end of
like a dingo like going out the back of
it like out the back of the tent but
like she said it was dark so she wasn't
entirely sure um
but since they had seen dingoes earlier
in the evening um
it just stood to reason that that's
probably what that was
so
she said that it's uh that the dingo had
got the baby
now uh obviously they call the police
the police show up the first guy to show
up at the scene was a guy named an
investigator named frank morris
now he has a flashlight he's kind of
like going in the tent and everything
and he notices some blood on one of the
rugs that's on the floor of the tent
and he did see some paw prints
leading away from the tent entrance
uh that kind of like faded out as they
went a little bit farther there you go
right there now now like i said this is
gonna get a lot more complicated like
before we get into it so don't get too
like [ __ ]
jacked over there
well i'm not saying that i'm just saying
that
it's not so much because i'm gonna say
right here i absolutely believe what
what the family said that the dingo
took the baby from the tent and ate the
baby
um it's plausible but well yeah but like
i'm saying what is
uh what's more interesting to me about
this case is the [ __ ] vilification
that she got and how everybody convinced
themselves that somehow
she had murdered this baby and then like
made it seem like a dingo took it
you know what i mean that to me gotta be
a motive
and yeah that's the pro i really she did
not have one but i'm just saying that
that's kind of yeah
so uh oh grampher said the bear eats
grizzly man first his girlfriend tries
to protect him then the bear eats her
yeah um
he called it too he knew that that was
the bear that was going to eat him
eventually yeah because he hung out with
bears for a really long time and he just
kind of knew hey that one's kind of a
dick you saw that bear and he goes
there's something wrong with that guy
like i said because if they're just like
people yeah they're not you can't yeah
he says if i get eaten by one of these
bears it's gonna be that one and he he
got it he called it right which is
creepy it was an old weak bear that
wasn't eaten um regularly
he was at the bottom of the bear food
chain
so uh he's a little cranky about it
yeah the other bears weren't hungry
they
they were getting plenty of food you
know catching fish and [ __ ]
so they they
they had the leeway you need to [ __ ]
around and play with a human
you know because they they didn't have
to eat everything that they saw like
that poor old guy
so yeah got eaten
that's the thing and i think i kind of
feel like if you hang out with the
animals long enough most of them will
not see you as food
well hell but you never know
yeah you never know if one's like a
psycho or one's like hungry or something
well you know they got mean ones but uh
you know in that particular case
he didn't have any problem hanging out
with strong healthy bears that were
getting plenty of food
they were getting fish like i said they
didn't see him as food you're right and
they're like this is entertainment i
don't know what this is but okay
whoo dance for me little hairless
whatever you are yes you don't look like
a fish you're all right but when you run
across the bear that isn't eating
because he's too old and too weak
that bears like i'm gonna eat this thing
he's like you know i don't like it's
trying to be friends with me but this is
not a bear
it's not a fish but there's enough on
them i could get some food off that it's
like yeah it's not a fish but it's also
not a bear yeah i don't know what it is
that's weird kind of monkey and i don't
like it yeah i'm kind of weird monkey is
not supposed to be here so that's what i
mean it's like i'm all i'm you know wild
animals
like i said i don't really like to yes
you can extrapolate like over oh this
species does this on the other but just
like everything else
animals are individuals and you have to
put yourself in the shoes these examples
i've made a living part of the time when
i wasn't doing other stuff working with
horses
you have to understand how they live and
how they were bred and
whether or not
and you know a [ __ ] bear is not a
herd animal it's it's it's an om it's an
omnivorous
um it's not a predator it's not an apex
predator it's
more kind of like uh
kind of creature that
just try it's like more like a
survivalist it's a general like
opportunity it's an opportunity they'll
just be whatever
they'll scavenge for garbage or if
something's like fresh and available
they'll eat that the reason why they're
still around is because they're not
specialized they're a generalist
kind of like a way a chimp or a monkey
or a human would be or a dog that's what
i'm saying a little bit of everything
yeah
so
in some ways that's kind of good because
it's not a predator
but in other ways it's kind of bad
because you're kind of on the same from
the point of view that barry you're on
the same level as it is
you're kind of a competitor
in a way because we're generalists also
yeah and if that sucker's hungry he
might decide you know what i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna eat this guy
which like i said from their point of
view understandable right because he's
like that's not a bear
yeah he's thinking that's not a bear
and i'm [ __ ] hungry yeah so i'm gonna
go ahead and eat this he's like he's
just waving his arms around like that
trying to be whatever right that's not a
bear he looks kind of delicious right
yeah
and he and i'm strong another thing is
is that all animals basically this is
with horses and everything
it's size ism they're sizes and female
and they know who's bigger
and if you're a [ __ ] old bear
it's gonna know what gender you are says
that's a dude
and it's not a bear dude and i'm bigger
than this [ __ ]
so i'm gonna eat him therefore into my
tummy he goes yeah oh it went red oh it
did
it's done that a couple of times yeah
but
oh
come on
oh it's back okay
i was gonna say it's done that a couple
of times but it's only done it for like
a couple of seconds okay so maybe it's
okay all right i mean i was kind of
hoping i'm not on that same day it is
storming out it is storming that's so i
don't really know we're gonna cut some
snack
um because it's been okay so far
but
it is storming out so you guys don't
know it's like it's thundering and stuff
it's not like
pouring pouring but it is thundering
um
so yeah so there was a little bit now
see here's the thing i've heard like we
like weird different
sources uh either there was a bunch of
blood in the tent or there wasn't that
much blood in the tent i kind of feel
like there maybe wasn't that much blood
in the tent which was one of the things
that
led people to believe that maybe this
was like a cover-up or something
but
apparently according the first
investigator on the scene said yes there
was some blood in the tent and he did
see some paw prints
so uh what they did was they had like
all the other campers because like i
said there were a ton of other people
in this because like i said it's [ __ ]
uluru it's ayers rock and it's a big
tourist destination so there's a lot of
campers there's a lot of hikers [ __ ]
like that so they got a bunch of people
to come out with flashlights and whatnot
and like do a search for the baby
so it was like 300 people so they did
like a whole human chain kind of
situation and they were looking for
tracks that they were looking for
anything now uh one thing that probably
didn't help like i said i'm not [ __ ]
on the family i don't really want to do
that and michael the dad um he's dead
now he died in 2017 of leukemia so i
don't like impugn the dead or anything
like that but
i am gonna say that his reaction to it
and like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
anybody's reaction to anything because
everybody reacts to things differently
but his reaction to stuff probably
didn't help the case later on down the
line although i'm sure he wasn't
thinking about that at the time because
he did kind of say something like
uh or at least one of the other campers
said that when they first set out to
like look for the baby after the dingo
had taken her
he basically just said she's probably
dead now
which
that's not true
but that's kind of a weird thing to say
though
i mean if you're the dad how long have
it had been
probably not long at this point not long
so i kind of feel like that's um if an
animal takes it it eats it right away
well yeah and like i said i know that
yeah um and that's
you know if you're coming at it from a
very cold like unemotional point
yes um i'm sure the baby is probably
dead by now because if an animal took it
it would probably like kill it
immediately because most animals do and
then we take it back to their lair and
eat it like i said from a logical point
of view from a spock point of view yes
that is probably true
but it's weird to say that out loud from
a human point of view
especially if that is your
baby it's pouring
yeah it is
it's pouring down okay we're lucky to
have it have a connection
yeah it's starting to come down yeah
okay so it's storming but hopefully
it'll be okay like i said yeah i kind of
like made some adjustments so maybe
i'm just saying and i'm not like like i
said i'm not i don't think they're
guilty i actually did i do think a dingo
took the baby and ate it um just like
they said i think it happened just like
they said but i'm just saying that the
way he reacted was probably not
super helpful because he did kind of
juice well well she's probably dead by
now like i said true
but
people are going to think that's weird
if you're just like real bald-faced
about it like that i kind of wouldn't
have just said that it was weird
but that's me
i'm a i'm a kind of a realist most
people would think it was great i'd be
like yeah that baby is dead probably
well yeah like i'm saying that is true
right but i most people wouldn't
i wouldn't react like that if that was
their baby most people would not react
like that most people but some people
would if
if a wild dog would just say dingo's
wild dog like a coyote or something you
know even though
i don't think they started off as wild
dogs they were domestic dogs that
returned to the wild
if it grabs
anything it's going to eat it's going to
grab it around the neck most likely and
it'll [ __ ] just kind of choke it out
so it won't struggle to make a bunch of
noise
so yeah it'll do that in the first few
minutes
yeah and i and dingoes which if you
don't know like are essentially like
wild dogs pretty much um just like any
predator yeah they'll usually try to
choke it out real quick yeah they'll try
to like get the neck or something like
that you know big cats do this as well
because they're just trying to like stop
the animal from struggling they don't
want to get hurt they'll lay down and
[ __ ] grab either so they'll just like
grab the neck until it stops moving and
then they'll you know they can eat it at
their leisure which i'm sure is what
happens
uh situation
so luckily they're not too painful
usually you can see it going you can see
that animals going through that like
gazelle so what i'm trying to say is the
baby wasn't eating alive
the baby was suffocated
well i mean the baby there was a lot of
blood uh they because i'll get into that
a little bit and the baby did cry like
holy like a holy [ __ ] kind of cry and
then it was cut off yeah um but from
what i could determine from the other
things that i've seen about other things
about dingoes eating babies or you know
at least like trying to get babies or
kids
which does happen and i'll get into that
a bit
but
like most predators like big cats stuff
like that they will go for the jugular
essentially they'll go for the neck
they'll just bite the neck and they'll
just like hang on hang on hang on hang
on until that stops struggling because
like i said they don't want to they're
just looking for food they don't want to
get hurt
so
they're not you know it's not mean
they're just that you can't carry around
a crying baby in the wilderness
yeah an animal's not going to do that no
it's going to choke it out
yeah and then like i said once it's dead
and they carry it around they'll they
will drag it back to their lair or
whatever and eat it whenever they play
with it for a while and then they'll eat
it which is horrible because it's a
human baby but like i said a dingo
doesn't know any better it's just food
to them yeah um you know like i said i'm
not i'm not making light of it it's
terrible but it's part of nature from
the animals point of view they don't
know any difference yeah
yeah so like i said the dad um
you know yeah he took a realistic view
of things and i think maybe that
that might have been one of the things
that contributed to um you know the
legal trouble they got into later
because people
misperceived them because not only were
they seventh-day adventists which you
know in australia at the time and even
nowadays uh is seen as a little bit
weird like a little bit culty
uh and especially back then 1980 in
australia it was seen as like very culty
so
they thought that um why are they acting
this way like when his baby just got
[ __ ] taken and you would think that
he would like spring into action and
like look for the baby instead of just
being like oh well it's probably dead
now
and like not really doing anything to
help that does seem a little weird um
everybody grieves differently i'm not
saying but
and the thing about it too and we'll get
into this a little bit later is that
however you react in this situation
because most people thankfully will not
have to put up you know will not have to
ever endure
anything where like where their baby is
like kidnapped or taken by an animal or
what have you
so when that horrible situation happens
i feel like people are always kind of
like scrutinizing the way the parents
react
and
if you react to
like laissez-faire if you're not
emotional enough
then that is seen as like an indictment
against you but if you're too emotional
then that's also seen an indictment
against you because everybody thinks
you're faking so i feel like you can't
really win no
and i kind of feel like lindy kind of
fell into that kind of [ __ ] as well
um
and she kind of knew that i feel like
she was like well whatever i do i can't
win so
and i kind of agree with her you can't
really win in that situation um you saw
the same thing and honestly lindy uh
came out in support of like remember we
did that thing about madeleine mccann
uh
it that happened in portugal when they
were on vacation and how everybody was
very very quick to blame the parents
because they weren't sad enough or
you know then
you know if you're not sad enough at the
beginning then if you cry later on oh
look at her she's faking so it's
whatever you do whatever reaction you
have people are gonna like read whatever
narrative they want to onto it so i kind
of feel like
um
lindy was kind of like yeah i'm just i
know how this game goes and she was kind
of like not
you know a lot of people thought they
were unemotional but
the thing about it is that some people
if something that horrific happens to
you their baby got taken by a [ __ ]
dog and eaten alive well not eaten alive
but eaten that's bad
and
i kind of feel like you don't know how
you would react in that situation you
might all your emotions might just shut
off because that's just kind of like the
way you're dealing with it and then the
media drives it with their little
[ __ ] story well that's what i'm
saying and and i'm gonna get into that
in a bit too because
i was like that chick who got accused of
murdering her roommate over there in
france remember the chick and the
boyfriend they made up all kinds of
stories about that was more kind of
recent they don't know who killed that
girl
remember that case what was that
madeleine wasn't a madeleine kind
i don't remember if it was a long time
ago that [ __ ] was sensational as [ __ ]
well i'm talking about well i was
talking about madeline mccann but that
was not a roommate that was the that
little baby no that little toddler that
was kidnapped and this was like two
girls in their 20s and remember and like
the one had her boyfriend over and then
they found the [ __ ] roommate dead
and i was over in france
i think it was in france they were
foreigners they weren't they weren't
from france
and then the french authorities [ __ ]
accused her and the boyfriend of [ __ ]
murder i'm not i'm not immediately i'm
thinking yeah i remember when that [ __ ]
was and no matter what those two did
they were saying that they were guilty
well and i think they actually convicted
her ass and they had no evidence to
prove it
from what i remember i think she may
have eventually gotten out well like i
said i kind of want to get into this on
this too because i kind of feel like
that's one of the things that bummed me
out like the most about this case is
amanda knox oh right right that's what
oh we haven't even done a show about
that yet yeah that's what he was talking
about amanda knox okay i'm gonna write
that down there was nothing she could
have done somebody mentioned that before
and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah we should do
that that's a massive [ __ ] case yeah
and we should probably do a show about
that i was i remember even back that's
right so i'm [ __ ] cynical and i was
going they were like oh and she's
hanging out with her boyfriend see look
at her she did it you know just like
that [ __ ] couldn't do anything anything
that [ __ ] would do they would [ __ ]
say that but that's what i'm saying
the thing about it though it's like you
know the media is good you need it to an
extent it's like you know you need
information and stuff but
uh the media going back to when it first
existed italy that's right yeah that was
italy um the media they still you know
as much as they want to like report on
stuff they want um
nowadays they want people to click on
their [ __ ]
uh what's going to cause people to click
on their [ __ ] is sensationalism outrage
so anything that causes
outrage or conflict or anything like
that is going to be taken over
a more boring truth because usually the
truth is a lot more boring or mundane
than any of us want to believe that
we're in there going crazy about amanda
knox and we need to do amanda knox and i
can't believe we haven't done a show
yeah yeah that [ __ ] with there was i had
totally forgotten about it said they
eventually overthrew that [ __ ] boy they
[ __ ] railroaded those two there was
no evidence and i don't think she did
that it was she had some dude over who
killed her and then he walked out
well like i said and the same thing
happened here and this was going back to
1980 yeah where i kind of feel like
people got the idea like i mentioned
before people really don't like this
kind of like random oh and animal just
like ate my baby and so they want to
like blame somebody they're like well we
can't punish an animal obviously so we
need to punish a person right so
even if they don't like uh punish the
person involved they're always like well
you shouldn't have and i i think i even
did it earlier well you shouldn't have
like fed the dingo earlier which you
shouldn't
but um i'm not blaming him for what
happened later because how would you
know but i'm just saying like in general
it's not a good idea but i'm just saying
that like people are very very quick to
want to blame somebody for something
um and even if it's absolutely not true
and it's really really like scary
how it can happen
so yeah you can happen to anybody man
that's why that's what i'm saying i'm
[ __ ] worried i'm gonna stay right
here in this goddamn house
well i mean nobody's dead around trust
but honestly if somebody dies around you
um
you probably should worry because
they're bringing up that that was italy
and not france of course yeah
and italy was notorious for that [ __ ]
italy would [ __ ] lock you up over
[ __ ] nothing if
if you look sideways in italy they give
you a conviction they'll say you
murdered somebody they did they have a
totally i remember when details are
coming out of how that legal system
works
italy has a totally anti-rational
criminal justice system but america kind
of does too uh we do also america so we
can't really cast asperger's but i think
they're even worse
because look i've been watching this
show i don't know if you guys i don't
know where it came from but like i saw
it on to be called bizarre murders and
they do it as like it's kind of larky
and like kind of funny and stuff but
because most of the stuff they do is
like [ __ ] crazy
but it's interesting
how
i mean you really have to to i mean to
be a cop you really have to like not
have any preconceived notions
because while there are
statistical
you know
for example
if somebody is murdered statistically
like if a woman is murdered
statistically
80 90 95 likely that it's somebody that
knew her boyfriend ex-boyfriend husband
you know somebody like that
um but not always you can't always
and i feel like there's still this human
tendency to
oh well we want it to be this person so
you like
sort of like finagle all of the
narrative to go in that direction and i
kind of feel like that's what happened
in this situation
everybody sort of decided not everybody
but
enough people decided that
lindy chamberlain had killed her baby
uh and that the dingo thing was uh a
cover-up
enough people decided that
that the evidence was almost kind of
like massaged in that direction i kind
of and you really really have to watch
that i mean
like i said it's very human it's really
really hard to get over it's really
really hard to look at things
impassively
um and it is
good to have um you know kind of a thing
where okay statistically this that the
other is more likely because that is
helpful
but you can't let that be the end all be
all because it's not always what
happened you can't always assume that
because
you know like i said for example because
for example it's way more likely for
when a woman turns up dead yes it's 80
90 95
uh that it was a boyfriend or
ex-boyfriend husband that did it most of
the time it is
but not always so you really can't
finagle all the evidence to
get to the
you know conclusion that you want that's
really not the best way to go about it
uh so i kind of feel like that's what
happened in this situation so this is
kind of like a um
you know a case where everyone should
kind of look at this and be like yeah
let's not like repeat this even though
it gets repeated like all the time
so uh so yeah so blood inside the tent i
said that before so all of the campers
come out everybody comes out 300 ass
people like different campers
investigators [ __ ] like that so they all
have flashlights and they're all like
looking for something like tracks
body clothing something
i mentioned earlier that michael said
some weird [ __ ] like she's probably dead
now which like i said weird thing to say
but you can't convict anybody on that
because people say weird [ __ ] when
they're
uh in when they're grieving obviously
um
after that apparently he also said i'm a
minister of the gospel again weird thing
to say
but not illegal you can't convict
somebody for saying weird [ __ ]
um
now the search at this point turns up
some more dingo tracks but they didn't
really find anything else significant
uh so this one guy who was another
tourist who was staying at the at the
rock his name was mori murray haybee i
think is how you pronounce his last name
uh he actually uh followed some dingo
tracks
under a ridge
and then he saw like a depression in the
sand
and he assumed like the tracks led up to
the depression and then in this
depression
it looked like
um
you know there was like a depression and
there was like a
an imprint of like um like fabric in the
depression like in the sand yeah
and so he was like oh well maybe the
dingo dragged the baby away and like set
it down here for a second like you know
while it was resting or whatever where
it was taking it uh to wherever it was
going to take it
so uh they did find that
now they followed the trail on from that
depression but didn't find anything else
now interestingly the first
investigators that showed up on the site
a couple of them were kind of like yeah
well yeah like the dingo took the baby i
mean obviously it seemed pretty obvious
from
the clues at the site
but according to uh one of the guys who
um
a guy named john bryson who talked who
was one of the guys there and he uh gave
testimony for the book later which is
called evil angels which was made into
the movie cry in the dark
he said uh we all went out you know
after we did the search and everything
we all went out to this bar we were like
talking about the case
now a couple of the investigators were
yeah were like yeah that's that's [ __ ]
up they didn't find the body obviously
um and they're like well yeah dingo took
the baby that's like that's [ __ ] up
but one guy one of the investigators
whose name was john lincoln he was not
having it
he basically said not a chance never
happened before
because i kind of feel like in 1980 i
don't know how uh accurate this is maybe
people from australia that were alive in
1980 could tell me but i kind of feel
like people had a perception of dingoes
as not that dangerous
in 1980
like maybe the way that we look at black
bears where they're dangerous but
you could deal with it like they
wouldn't take a baby or anything like
that so i kind of feel like people
kind of still had that perception oh
it's just like a dog which they are but
not i mean
even a domestic dog will kill a baby
under the right such like situation so i
don't know
yeah some of them well so i don't know
what happened to that dog that's what
i'm saying so i don't really know why
people are like so weirded out by like a
dingo
killing a domestic human will kill a
baby depending on the [ __ ] human but
that's what i'm saying but i mean just
to compare apples to apples yeah i'm
just saying like even a domesticated dog
under the wrong circumstances
would kill a
child or a baby yeah so i don't really
see why people find it so
strange that a dingo would do the same
that's just looking for food but okay
but this guy was apparently the dingo
expert
of all experts because you know how
those dudes are
i know everything
and that just never happens it's never
happened
so i kind of feel like this attitude
prevailed a little bit um even though a
lot of investigators were you know
at first inclined to take her word for
it because that seemed pretty cut and
dried
uh but a couple but enough of them
weren't that there was some question
raised
some of the other investigators said hey
you know there have been some dingoes
around like these campgrounds and they
have like attack they haven't killed
anybody
so far but they had like attacked
little kids and stuff
at this point john lincoln says
you know no dingo
could carry a 10-pound baby
all the way back to its lair come on
wait what do you do you really believe
well that's what i'm saying yeah he's
full of history it's like you can't
really and then he apparently according
to one of the other investigators says
he brings out like he filled up he went
so far as to like fill up a 10-pound
bucket with sand
and put it in his mouth it was like look
look how hard it is no that's not how it
works and well yeah and i'm just kind of
saying
a bucket doesn't have a nice big soft
neck that you could pick up a bucket is
not a baby but a bucket does not have a
baby neck nope no a bucket is not made
of meat no it's not shaped the same
right that is really really no dog
that's a very very bad technology
dogs have been around and things like
dogs have been around for millions and
millions of years they [ __ ] grab
things and drag them off and eat them
especially if they're in the packs
they're evolved for that i mean that's
kind of their thing you give a [ __ ]
you can give a dog
a turkey carcass fresh thawed turkey
carcass and go here eat that and that
dog will [ __ ] grab that thing and
drag it off well yeah and eat it
lay down with it and lick on it and pull
it apart yeah look what i got
dude's tripping
he's like a tribute yeah obviously of
course a dingo can eat a baby of course
yeah and here's the thing a domestic dog
might eat a baby sure especially if a
domestic dog says well this isn't part
of our family this is i don't know where
this came from
this is a random thing
is that a human what is that that's a
chicken i'm gonna eat that
dogs don't have it it's soft yeah dogs
do not
that a human has
you know they're like yeah that's a baby
but you know
my master that's not my master's baby
because
they're pack animals
yeah and they [ __ ] see
their
[ __ ] owners as their family and their
pack
other people are not in their pack
you can do whatever you want to them
you know depending on what kind of dog
you are but no i [ __ ]
you know if that dog was hungry then i'm
going to eat this the dog would eat you
yeah i mean to me that sounds like
ridiculous i kind of feel like even if
it was 1980 yeah i know it was a long
time ago i was eight years old yeah
but the fact that like some apparently
smart police detective yeah apparently
not smart because of this argument but
he comes in he's like i'm that's that
doesn't happen he's more a dingo can't
[ __ ] drag baby
he had already decided he decided that
[ __ ] yeah that that couldn't happen yeah
people have a tendency to project their
[ __ ] moral framework onto other
people
and and sometimes on on animals well you
come to a conclusion first and then you
look for [ __ ] that will back it up yeah
is is something that a lot of people do
you really have to like be aware of that
though i mean uh okay the sweetest dog
you know
you know i don't know because we have
foreigners from all around the world you
know i got assad he's up in saudi arabia
he listens to he's a regular listener
and [ __ ] message me he likes animals
he's seeing videos man man showing him
[ __ ] things that
dogs can do you know saudi arabia they
don't really have dogs
um just that culture just wasn't did not
evolve in a place that had an abundance
of animals
uh camels and desert type animals
lizards and [ __ ] but
you know [ __ ] dogs and cats you know
they don't really have well they have
cats cats go back to persia and [ __ ]
oh the arabian and persians they [ __ ]
love cats
egyptians had cats but not dogs so much
they got them but they're just kind of
they're in a different situation all
right if you
can take the sweetest of dog breeds
a doberman
[ __ ] not dover excuse me [ __ ]
labrador
labrador's sweetest smoke breed you
could get just a general purpose generic
western dog
if that labrador is hungry
okay
it could easily eat a baby especially if
it's never seen a baby well if a person
was hungry enough they would probably i
mean they'd have to be really hungry to
be fair but
if a person was hungry enough they would
eat another person if you had a starving
labrador walking around who was never
really raised by a family this is like a
feral labrador and it sees a little baby
a defenseless little baby
that labrador might go i don't know what
this is
i'm gonna eat it
and there's no there's no malevolence or
anything into it yeah they don't mean it
it was just about i don't know what this
is
i'm not [ __ ] on the poor dingo no he
was just hungry no and the idea of it
being a human baby that doesn't even
enter into a damn dog's mind not not
he's not a wild dog not a not a dog that
is feral or not a dog that's part of
somebody's family not a family dog
something that's been raised around
people and have seen babies and has
experiences it might go well
i'm not really supposed to eat these
yeah i better know it i'm probably not
supposed to eat because this might this
is this is a people you know but if
you're dealing with they're you know
they're dogs
you're not talking about a huge super
high i mean they're smart they're small
they're not that smart yeah it's more
emotion you know
and if
dingo has never had a human family or
those kind of relationships you're like
i'm going to eat this
that's what i mean it's like it's little
and soft
yeah it has nothing to do with ferocity
nothing it's just opportunity
this is me i'm gonna eat it well and as
i said the dingoes particularly in this
area i mean there were you have to think
too that this is a
high like tourist area there are a lot
of tourists um you know hikers and stuff
and a lot of people camping around there
so they were probably used to hanging
out and getting food from campgrounds
yeah and then they get this little baby
and then [ __ ] dingo's like well they
don't guess they don't want this one
yeah they just listed here yeah they
left it here so they don't want this one
they don't know the difference they
don't they're not human beings so
they're not they're not they're just
hungry
but so i think that's very human wants
to project into this animal somebody
yeah like an investigator
grew up apparently in australia yeah and
knew about dingoes was all kind of like
oh a dingo wouldn't do that of course
they couldn't do that of course they
would elaborate
of course like i said a domestic dog
would do that yeah a feral domestic a
wild dog absolutely yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely that's not weird at all yep
if you left okay domestic dogs have had
their masters die in the house
and they can't get out of the house
because they can't open a door so what
do they do they eat the dead master
i mean what would you do what would you
do same thing right that's what i mean
don't judge right
murder hornet says domestic dogs have
killed adults absolutely yeah that's
what i mean that's why i don't think
it's weird
domestic dogs attack people
all the time you can order a domestic
dog to kill us so i don't really
understand like why he found that so
hard to believe yeah
um but okay
okay yeah uh but yeah so he was just
like yeah that doesn't happen
now uh
so there was that yeah
well i don't know if it was so much that
he was like oh dingos don't do that or
he's like oh a dingo is not capable of
dragging a baby that large that far
because like i said they didn't find the
body spoiler alert they never did find
it they still haven't as far as i know
um he's like you know it's their mouth
isn't big enough like for the baby's
head blah blah he had like all these
[ __ ] uh arguments
now uh so he did the whole bucket thing
which you know i i don't know how how
well they took that but that seemed like
a stunt and
again that's completely different to
what we're talking about so i don't know
why it's relevant but okay
now a week later after the baby had
disappeared azaria
um
this guy called wally goodwin he goes
out um at the base of uluru
and he's gonna he doesn't have anything
to do with the case or anything like
that he's just out there like taking
pictures i'm getting pictures from
mexico of dogs [ __ ] eating dudes
[ __ ] dicks off
well there you go
don't show that alleged alleged rapist
punished by the cartels by second of
dogs well now was he
if he was in action
then i'm okay with that yeah if he's an
alleged rapist and they don't have any
proof
i heard about that case before he said
that
what the deal was is that he was an
alleged pedo who would rape somebody's
kid
so the cartels got him and
stripped him naked and [ __ ] sent the
[ __ ] pitbull at him and that's
pulling his just that's
his dick right off if that's true yeah
then i'm not bothered it may be
it may be
but i don't know i i'm uncomfortable
with like not knowing for sure
that that dude did that if some dude
just said that he did that yeah that's
[ __ ] up
but if they know that he did that i
think they know that i don't have it i
think they know i've been hearing about
that case because maybe they'll learn
probably they won't but okay well you
know you have with the parallel
structures in mexico because the
government doesn't handle certain
business so the cartels handle business
it's the same thing the [ __ ] mexican
ma the the italian mob was all about
where it went back to the hockey
motherland and [ __ ] sicily and [ __ ]
during the damn ottoman [ __ ] invade
or what did they call it when uh
when the uh when when the ottomans
occupied the area the [ __ ] italian
government went underground and they
started [ __ ] dealing their own
justice out you know
parallel governments so
parallel governments people it can get
messy
so yeah so a week after the baby
disappears
a dude named wally goodwin uh he's going
out uh at the base of uluru or ayers
rock if you would rather
um he doesn't have anything to do with
the case he's just out there taking
pictures like wildflowers and stuff
and while he's out there
he finds uh some shredded bloody
clothing
that are resting near a like a big rock
a boulder
now uh when the authorities are called
in this proves to be a jumpsuit
and a torn diaper
so he reports his findings to
the authorities because like i said
everybody's heard about this case at
this point
so they go in there and the thing about
this is that so they find
okay
they find the baby's jumpsuit which she
was wearing in her little diaper
and they're all torn up i've seen photos
of
the jumpsuit that they found
um
don't google it if you don't want to
think about it because
it looks pretty bad so the jumpsuit
it's pretty much a baby jumpsuit and
it's just like all blood from here down
and the um like torn off and there's
like some blood on there too
so
you know
i can imagine like what probably
happened not not a fun thing to imagine
um
you know so there was that but
everything was like all [ __ ] shredded
up
so that was found the jumpsuit that the
baby had been wearing and the diaper
or nappy as they call it in the uk and
australia
now interestingly uh august 28th which
was a little bit after that
um
this guy named detective sergeant graham
charlwood takes over the investigation
now
i'm not [ __ ] on this guy either in
particular although i do kind of feel
like the authorities really [ __ ] uh
drop the ball [ __ ] the bed piss down
their leg whatever
metaphor you want to use
uh on this case because they had
for whatever reason decided we're gonna
like blame somebody for this [ __ ] so
they have to like [ __ ]
get everything in on that
so uh even the guy
one of the inspectors gilroy who
weirdly enough
was on the chamberlain's side
and he seemed to
think that okay their uh their
assertion of like what happened was
relevant but
he still kind of like
took all these statements from
[Music]
some wacky ass like [ __ ] [ __ ] so
listen to this crap
so he starts out he's like okay well
the doctor
of the baby
you know their pediatrician or whatever
the pediatrician apparently comes
forward
and says oh well
i don't think he outright said oh i
think the parents did it but he's like
oh i thought it was weird when the
parents brought the baby in for the for
the checkup
and the baby had a black dress on
which
okay i mean this is 1980
i get it it's like
this was even like before satanic panic
like full on satanic panic but i kind of
feel like it was maybe
this is maybe early satanic thing
um i will note that in the early 1980s
it was kind of like fashionable to where
to dress your kids in like dark clothing
like navy or black or something like
that but usually it had kind of like
bright colored flowers on it that was
kind of like a thing
in the early 1980s i kind of remember
but
the fact that this baby had a black
dress on
allegedly i don't know if she did uh was
kind of a big deal this doctor
this doctor also said
that oh i thought her name azaria the
baby's name was weird
so i looked it up and he said
that the name meant
sacrifice in the wilderness
what
absolutely not true
the name azaria actually means
helped by god
but nice try
so the doctor i don't know if they're
like their pediatrician is like trying
to like get [ __ ] famous now
so he's trying to like put some satanic
panic [ __ ] on the [ __ ] and it worked
will you resist again 1980 okay yeah
satanic panicura that's what i was just
saying
you got cookies and you bring me
something
what kind of cookie is that um
okay i can't eat it cause i'm like
talking you know what
i can't eat it because i'm talking
there's another hat for it everybody
says curly wig
you can use a cookie
everybody says curly wig what's curly
wig your curly wig
oh i get it man
how many cookies oh okay these are from
[ __ ] dollar general store
these were [ __ ] a dollar you guys
brought a big old pack of [ __ ]
vanilla a week or two ago he spent 60
dollars at dollar general buying soda
and cookies and cookies
yeah for the for the top floor
refrigerator
[Laughter]
i mean
prices went up
what do you want me to do about it
nothing okay thank you
but yeah so
yeah so i don't know like satanic panic
so the fact that the baby allegedly i
don't even know if this is true had a
dark colored dress on
the fact that the baby was named azaria
which he said he looked up and that
meant
sacrifice in the wilderness which it
absolutely does not but okay
so he reported that to police and the
police kind of went with it
like i said satanic panic it was a whole
different era although like i said it
still happens nowadays
so um
this same investigator who was
apparently supposedly
on their side
also said oh well her clothing was found
where the family were hiking earlier
that day thank you no need for me too
kicking in for tom's dollar general
budget
yeah he could buy
five packs of cookies with that i'm
looking like you look like um dexy's
midnight runners groucho marx oh i
thought you look like harpo like a
heartball i thought you were gonna start
thinking come on eileen
you do kind of look like one of them
mark's brothers yeah yeah you like hawk
a horn or something i'm good okay
[Music]
the cookies are good
there well
i can't eat mine until you talk well
here
okay i'm gonna talk i'm gonna talk so
you can eat the cookie thank you
jenny
go ahead and eat it
well you're not talking though no as
soon as you start eating it i'll talk
jenny always like to have some vanilla
up in her mouth she got that vanilla
gorilla up in the damn go ahead and chew
it jenny go ahead and chew it
see see how the sexy see how the sexy
red lipstick up against i thought you
were going to talk about something like
up against that interesting that vanilla
wafer
big old thick brown vanilla wafer
inch in diameter vanilla wafer up and
down mouth
see it's all that oral fixation
what kind of
okay that's it
do you think it was good wouldn't it
told you it was good i talked through
the whole thing
they didn't yeah i did i'm talking right
now i'm not done okay there you go
the vanilla cookies are you get a big
old pack of vanilla cookies they're like
[ __ ] a foot square for a dollar
this is why americans are fat for like a
dollar
got the vanilla ones the lemon ones the
lemon ones are kind of like those
mcdonald's cookies you know but no
they're like that i mean to be honest of
all the ones the lemon ones are probably
yeah they're the best ones but they they
were vanilla is like second tier didn't
have then they had a peanut butter ones
they were like the [ __ ] they were all
right they're all right
and then they had uh
uh a copy of uh
oreos also known as like hydrox cookies
i'm not super into like the chocolate
cookie
white cream
combination i like them all right
they're okay i'll i'll eat them if
there's nothing else around
but i'm more into like vanilla lemon
yeah i don't really like the chocolate
then for a dollar 25 you get one of
those big old packs it's got like
coconut macaroon cookies and oh now
those are good oh yeah
the other ones with the damn
marshmallow cookies with the hood
covered in chocolate okay but
marshmallow can go eat a dick though i
don't like marshmallows marshmallow can
go eat a dick yes you don't like the
marshmallow cookie no
i was looking
for the sunshine
brand
um
lemon cooler cookies remember lemon
cooler cookies
you guys don't know what that is if
you're in another country
it was just a white cookie with lemon
it's instead of chocolate chips it had
lemon flavored chips and it was covered
in white powdered sugar they were
[ __ ] great they're kind of like
wedding cookies like a wedding cookie
lemon came in a [ __ ] green box with a
[ __ ] yellow top on them they're gone
that company's out of business
they're around forever i mean they still
have those though oh yeah i'm looking
for them couldn't find them you gotta
look that [ __ ] up you even have that
puppet
well like i said look up the different
brand names because
yeah there's always like an alternative
for everything
to talk about homemade snickerdoodles
i've made those in a long time yeah
those are good man we made some
snickerdoodles like i mean that was a
couple that was ginger snaps yeah she's
talking about homemade chocolate chip
cookies and peanut butter cookies fresh
out of the yeah oh yeah
yeah they're good i mean probably
everybody getting fat just talking about
it i know
yeah that's how we do
like dude i've got like a quarter
through this [ __ ] is that it yeah okay
keep going
it's still relatively early
that's true
it's like it's wednesday so we're not
going anywhere yeah and i have to say
we've had a couple little hiccups
but it seems to be going i don't want to
say anything out loud
because i'll curse it
but
it seems to be okay seems to be okay
but yeah so what the living cooler
cookies
yeah tila says [ __ ] now i'm craving
cookies and donuts tammy tom yeah
honestly i haven't had a doughnut in
such a long time and the other day i was
like man i really want a [ __ ] donut
yeah
i haven't had a donut and i don't know
how many years
lemon cooler that's what they look like
all american like i said they kind of
look like wedding cookies but they're
like lemon flavored that's what the
cookies themselves look like
man they were good
they were really good i mean pretty much
anything lemon flavored they're living
flavored
i love lemon flavored desserts trying to
find them it's one of my favorite things
yeah
one of my favorite things
uh okay so where was i oh there's the
[ __ ] retro package that's it that's
it look at your hair yeah my hair is
[ __ ] up
that was the package i remember
that [ __ ] was ghetto as [ __ ] but when
they were [ __ ] good oh my god that
sunshine remember that yeah as it was
ghetto it was do you know what's funny i
think that font is called
bauhaus the house yeah
i think
she was oh you lit the [ __ ] up look at
look at what you did yeah that [ __ ] was
ghetto as [ __ ] well yeah they're good
they got a recipe on how to make
okay that's what i'm telling you okay
look everything that you thought of back
in those it's the internet it's the 21st
century
anything that you thought of of your
childhood if you grew up in the 70s or
80s
everybody has a recipe for replicating
it yeah
any anything you want you can make it at
home you can make it at home
yeah right yeah oh my goodness you're a
hot mess right now yeah
he doesn't care i don't care he doesn't
care no
so so yeah here's the thing
one of the main investigators on the
case this is what's weird to me gilroy
he seemed like even though he seemed to
initially buy the story that they told
which for the record i think was
probably exactly what happened
then he tried to like subvert it as time
went on because he was kind of like well
uh you know i got this statement from
this doctor that they brought in like
this baby with black clothes on and her
name means
sacrifice in the wilderness which it
doesn't but whatever and like he bought
it
he also says oh the clothes were found
uh close to where they had hiked earlier
in the day like he was trying to suggest
that
they had left the [ __ ] there i don't
know it's like he was trying to suggest
some [ __ ] she was pissed that i'm making
her hungry that's now she wants now she
wants [ __ ] um nilla wafers and
[ __ ] nana pudding jenny does not like
banana i don't know what it is i [ __ ]
love i don't know i'm not a big fan of
nana and man i'm putting with nil away i
mean
regular bananas
fine that [ __ ] is mississippi as [ __ ]
but
i mean my grandma used to make nana put
in
i don't like banana i don't like
artificial banana flavor of anything i
haven't made it in forever man and
they've got nilla wafers down there
they got it down there and the pudding
that [ __ ] is just a [ __ ] southern
classic
well it's in the cookbook but yeah
it's not i'm not like like i said my
grandma used to make it all the time but
i never ate it
you're right i like food i like nilla
waiting for him he lives all the way up
and [ __ ] all the way up as san
francisco california as she had she
knows nilla wafers and [ __ ] that
important you know she's black
you know i like the way backers on their
own
um i've eaten nana puddin with nilla
wafers yeah it's just i'm not a fan i'm
not a fan of banana flavored anything if
any of you i don't like bananas if any
of foreigners don't know we're talking
about get get our cookbook or you can
look that [ __ ] up online [ __ ] nana
pudding
n-a-n-n-a
p-u-d-d-i-n nana put vanilla wafers
n-i-l-l-a nilla wafers your hair is
cracking i'm not [ __ ]
this [ __ ] here
that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's it's bananas with banana with with
pudding
and [ __ ] you can eat you're cooking
them another way or banana pudding yeah
my grandma usually use whipped cream and
it's layered in there and it's just get
it with a [ __ ] spoon and you gotta
let it age for about a day
so all the [ __ ] cookies get kind of
moist it's just it's beautiful
it's beautiful and it's just a deep
south
thing
that [ __ ]
black people know about it southerners
know about it
they all take that [ __ ] up north and
sell to soul food all southern food is
soul food so i'll say
it's
you know everybody's gonna have their
own spin on it but that's that's a great
dessert and now i'm [ __ ] hungry for
it i'm gonna blame t for that she's
blaming me i'm blaming her
because she brought that one up maybe
you should like not i'm gonna make
something she's blaming me for making
her hungry own your own your own will i
gotta get out of here
i've had enough i've had enough of this
dude i've been like i've got like a
quarter through the kitchen okay go
ahead good thank you
he says go ahead cause he's leaving
all right
so where was i all right so
this is what confuses me because this
inspector who seemed to believe as i
said their
uh you know
their uh theory of what happened or
their you know uh assertions of what
happened
he really seemed to like undermine
their
uh
sequence of events at every turn
you know i got this [ __ ] from this
doctor that said this [ __ ] which is like
[ __ ] crazy whatever
um
and he also noted and this is a quote as
far as i'm aware
he said
oh well all the people around at the
campsite they quote unquote assumed she
was holding a baby
when they have seen her holding a white
bundle to her breast so he's implying
that
she had killed the baby at some point
prior and then was like faking it
which
seems like a lot of trouble but okay
now uh at this point so okay so
it's kind of like the media
at this point
i don't know i kind of feel like they're
going i don't know if they've gone all
in on the we're blaming the mom
situation
i feel like it's kind of like right in
the middle
but they are kind of doing an
investigation at this point
so they do uh
they're kind of like testing blood
they're testing like grass and [ __ ] like
that around where the baby might have
been taken
they're doing hair samples [ __ ] like
that they were found on the baby's
clothes which they found earlier there
was kind of a big thing too about
the
okay so there was like a jumpsuit there
was a diaper and i think there was like
a little bit of like another
garment like underneath like a little
bit of a singlet i don't know if it was
the same thing
um but they found that
and it was inside out so there was like
a big huge deal about
well a dingo would not have been able to
like pull a baby out of a piece of
clothing and like
make the clothes go inside out which
you know made people think oh well
obviously there was something else going
on so that was another thing that uh
that lended itself to this whole
situation uh they also like shot a bunch
of dingos in the area of uh uluru
and uh
the ones that they shot they like cut
them up like looking for human proteins
like in their stomach
i mean
the baby
was only nine weeks old
now
babies at that age their bones are
pretty soft i know this is like a weird
[ __ ] up
thing to be talking about
but from a scientific standpoint uh from
a predator standpoint
babies are their bones are soft they
haven't like hardened yet
so
if an animal ate them
then you would presume that the animal
maybe ate all the bones as well because
they were so soft not like in a grown-up
bones
so they were looking for that in
the dogs that they shot uh they didn't
find anything however i will note that
in the tent
which backs up lindy and michael's story
they did find some dog-like hairs found
in the tent like i said there was a [ __ ]
ton of blood
but
there was some blood
and they did find some dog hairs and
they did find some kind of like dingo
footprints outside uh which corroborated
lydia and michael's uh story
so
at this point as i said i kind of feel
like
there was some
contingent
of
media authorities that were leaning
toward
lindy and to a lesser extent michael had
killed their baby for whatever reason
and were blaming it on dingo
so they were kind of like
as i mentioned massaging the evidence
shall we say like that
in that direction
so
what they were doing was like well okay
we found this piece of clothing a week
after the baby disappeared
which was
like i said if you want to google it you
can there are pictures of it online
of the uh the onesie that the baby was
wearing
and
yeah it to me
it looks like
the baby got grabbed by the head as a
predator would do
and probably shook the baby's head this
is not pleasant to think about but
probably shook the baby's head to break
the neck
i would imagine because that's what a
lot of predators do
and um you know so there's a lot of
blood from that
and
then probably like dragged it out
but for whatever reason
um
because they wanted
the parents to be responsible somehow
they were just kind of like well
could a dinga really do that i kind of
feel like
the blood pattern on the onesie and the
way that there was like a
a cut on the neck of the garment
that
some experts claimed was from scissors
or from a blade and not from a canine
tooth
so
they made the argument that
that somebody a human had slashed the
baby's throat prior
and then had like made it look like
a dingo had done it
so
there's that
now one of the main pieces of evidence
that fueled the interest because like i
said i kind of feel like most of the
investigators
at first
were inclined to
believe
the chamberlain's um you know series of
events which
like i said i kind of feel like that's
probably what happened
however there was a significant uh
you know kind of contingent that thought
that maybe that wasn't what happened
and one of the things that contributed
to their like kind of uh evidence in the
case
there were some ultraviolet photographs
of azaria's jumpsuit which was found a
week after she disappeared
now there was this guy named james
cameron not that one
he was a forensic scientist from
britain
he was from the london hospital uh
medical college
and he said
that looking at the ultraviolet photos
of the garment that was found
said that the wound around the neck of
the jumpsuit
looked like
a cutthroat
he also alleged
that there was an imprint
of the hand of a small adult
on the jumpsuit like in blood
so he is
that
implying
mom
yeah
killed the baby
by cutting the throat
and then made it look like
a dingo had done it
which you just got to think about this i
mean this is very far-fetched but like i
said this is the chance this is 19.
they go camping to kill the baby and
make this big fun it's just not so
[ __ ] unlikely
it is it's just so i don't know i'm
going to say i think it's far more
likely they go camping dog comes in
listen
if you're in a weird cult i'm just going
to say right now if you're in a weird
cult and you decide hey let's kill our
baby like as a sacrifice
yeah yeah um
this is really not the best way to go
about it yeah let's see like don't do
that i'm just saying that like if you
were gonna do that hypothetically yeah
this is really not how you do it the
best yeah yeah let me introduce you to
cal southern california california
weird cults all right not not that they
sacrifice people but when you see what a
weird cult was really like no
no
cults [ __ ] actually more centered
around [ __ ] sex and money
sure you know
not so much this but you know exactly
well like i said human sacrifice sells
yeah it's uh it's scandalous this is a
thing it's outrageous
people want to read about it
so
even if you're in a cult and it's like
super boring
probably it's far more likely that the
dingo ate the baby
that's yeah
i mean obviously
it seems very obvious to me
that they're trying to blame something
they're trying to blame a person i got
yeah i got into that earlier and i kind
of feel like that's it's a very human
thing i'm not [ __ ] on humans in
general but it is a very common human
thing you want to blame an intelligent
force whether it's human whether it's
alien whether it's a conspiracy whether
it's something you want to blame an
intelligent force for some [ __ ] when
most of the time
it's probably just like random there are
many recorded cases of women killing
their babies
sure they don't look like this they
don't look anything like this
you know
and like i said i think that's one thing
that clouds the waters of cases like
this because
you know no one's saying there aren't
cases of like crazy-ass moms that killed
their babies obviously
that has happened they just don't look
like this um
they kill their babies at home
and i mean you know yeah as as uh it's
over hyped yeah but there have been
cases of like cult sacrifice like i said
it's
point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of the [ __ ]
uh as much as the media would like
especially back in this day
where everything was like [ __ ]
satanic panic
but
it doesn't happen as often as you think
but if it does happen then obviously the
media's gonna pick it up on it and run
with it because people want to read
about it because it's crazy
so
like i said it's not entirely the
media's fault
uh it's also the fault of the people
that read about it because you're the
one
fueling it
if you didn't read about it they
wouldn't print it
you know what i'm saying or put it on
the internet uh
in common parlance like nowadays because
if nobody read it they wouldn't publish
it
so
i don't know everyone's everyone's kind
of responsible if it's on the news
they're guilty exactly that happens a
lot
i mean and it's really sad in this
particular case because their baby was
lost in a horrible horrible way yeah and
that was like completely random
and the fact that they spent years and
years and years i mean years decades of
their lives
fighting against this yeah lindy spent
years in prison
uh and
you know we'll get into that but it's
just like and tease like they shed all
these damn dingos yeah they shot all the
damn bears
they shot all the bears that's what i'm
saying because uh well yeah they shot
all the bears because uh
a woman from india went down in her
garage and accidentally trapped a bear
between the garage between the car and
the wall and the [ __ ] bear ran past
her and knocked her over so they go out
and [ __ ] kill about [ __ ] 10 bears
because the bear panicked because it's
like oh my god you're between me and the
accent and the exit right sure and the
bear didn't mean to hurt her i don't
think and
they're not from here they don't grow up
in these areas they're it's not just
indian people it's just people that are
not from the south and not from florida
a lot of them come from new york they're
not used to having nature
they'll say that [ __ ] nature
environmentalists but then they come
here and they want you to kill all the
damn [ __ ] wildlife
it pisses me off i'm growing up with the
[ __ ] and i'm going like leave the
[ __ ] bears alone they're just trying
to eat out of garbage i mean we are in
creature encroaching on their
[ __ ] on their territory right you can't
blame them they call animal control and
animal control is only well they're
paying us to be here
so i guess we got to kill every bear in
this area and that's i mean we were
there when the animal control showed up
yeah
um they were not happy
yeah the animal controlled wasn't happy
about it they're because i came home
from work yeah you were out in the
driveway yeah animal control van was
here was at our old house
that's cussing them out why are you
killed on damn bears yeah when i pulled
up and i was like what the [ __ ] is going
on and it's like well that thing
happened with like that woman and like
that bear grabbed her by the head or
whatever it wasn't our neighborhood but
it was like one a couple uber
and
it didn't kill her
no she was she was already knocked her
over it did drag her a little bit so it
was just trying to get her out of the
way and then it ran off yeah it didn't
like yeah it didn't want to eat her yeah
just wanted a garbage can yeah it was
just like oh move oh my god the garbage
can was inside the garage yeah and it
was in there getting the garbage can she
walked in so it was that and they shot
seven bears yeah
and they shot um
i'm pretty sure they shot that bear that
we saw
that baby one that was climbing over our
fence yeah yeah
pretty sure they shot that one it's
[ __ ] it's a waste and then they then
these same [ __ ] are voting for
all this environmental protectionism
[ __ ]
and then they'll go and kill every
[ __ ] damn brother well like i said
you just have to understand like look
i'm a liberal i'm an environmentalist
but i understand you can't encroach
on wild animals territory
and expect them to
uh just like bow down and like literally
live there right yeah
uh they're like this is my
area [ __ ] i don't know why you're here
they have their own jobs to do sure and
their own [ __ ] to do and [ __ ] you
gotta let these animals do what they
gotta do this is what they are of course
you stand your ground you don't let them
in your house or anything but you don't
want to go [ __ ] call animal control
and kill all the goddamn animals i would
because they knocked you over no you
know
and honestly if the bear had done that
i've been like okay fair play because
the bear didn't do anything to her just
knocked her over
it didn't even hurt her really no but
she flipped out yeah she flipped out
right and then seven bears died because
of yep
she didn't kill anybody like that bear
didn't kill anybody no it was just
scared none of those bears killed
anybody
no
and that it that really bums and there's
really no so like i said look if you
want to live in the [ __ ]
wilderness
you want to live in like a [ __ ] rural
area
then you have to understand that animals
were there before you yeah and they
still think that's their [ __ ] it is
their [ __ ] right felicia right police
[ __ ] yeah you're encroaching on their
[ __ ] right so your [ __ ] laying out and
not protecting it belongs to them yep
and that's why i said that's why you
should keep your cats inside keep your
animals inside
be careful with your garbage
um you know just take precautions
but if animals are in europe like don't
shoot them or nothing like that that's
their [ __ ] territory man they're
people too they don't know no it's hard
yeah in a way here's the thing they have
minds that are actually more
sophisticated than cats and dogs yeah in
terms of bears
so you have to understand that yeah
they're dangerous but those are [ __ ]
sentient animals they were here before
you were [ __ ] they were here before you
were and they're not waging war on you
they're just trying to get some [ __ ]
food sure you have to be tolerant
towards the thing that's what i mean
don't approach it like oh my god they're
[ __ ] with me specifically right no
they're not they just
right so you don't let them bully you
you stand your own ground you protect
your house they have that sensibility
about them they know your house from
their house
they know when they're in the in your
house
you just gotta let you can't come in
this house
you know you're in my territory but that
[ __ ] bear didn't do anything to her
other than i was just trying to get away
so try to get out yeah it just kind of
like knocked her over because it was
it was steel it was in her garage and
she was stealing in her garage and it
knew it was and just trying to get out
of there
yeah it wasn't trying to hurt her it was
hard to eat her it was just kind of like
oh [ __ ] like i'm somewhere i'm not
supposed to be yeah they know they get
out of my way they know about stealing
yeah but you know you'd steal two if
that's if you had to live off the land
that's what i'm saying right so i try to
see things from like the animal's point
of view and
you know so don't be a dick that's all
i'm saying just don't be a dick about
like especially if you want to live in
rural areas please don't be a dick about
animals they don't like know
about your human like oh i own this land
they're like yeah i don't understand
that concept you know what i mean it's
like dr matt wanted me to [ __ ] kill a
damn bobcat that was eating his chickens
and i said doctor matt you know
absolutely not i said do you real you do
realize that that bobcat is a [ __ ]
apex predator for this area for every 10
prey animals there's only one predator
that animal deserves to be here
okay and you can sacrifice a chicken or
two
okay this is yeah a bobcat is a cat
a big cat all right and it's just trying
to survive
and and you know what he went yeah
you're right
i said because i said thank you i said i
asked your wife if i could kill some of
those deers i got a bow oh yeah you know
i mean i wanted to you know and she
wouldn't let me do it she doesn't want
me to kill the prey animals but you want
me to kill predator animals i said
that's
backwards in nature okay and he goes
yeah you're right
so he is he trapped the [ __ ]
um
the uh the bobcat let it go relocated it
and let it go good right
good i mean prey animals like deer are
supposed to be eaten they
reproduce in large numbers they're
genetically programmed for that to
[ __ ] try to i mean don't make them
suffer yeah but they're compensating for
predation sure they have a there
more of them are born every year but
predator animals they're they're they're
not many
their their reproduction is a lot lower
there's not as many of them
they're at the top of the [ __ ] food
shape at the the
at the food pyramid
so you don't you're not really supposed
to be hunting predators okay there's not
that many of them yeah
right they're not meant to be eaten
that's not really
how nature works and kind of i feel like
nowadays in the 21st century in the
united states depending on where you
live
um
if you're hunting
don't be hunting all that much and like
honestly you should just be hunting what
you can eat yeah how would you eat and
you hot prey animals don't cut like
stuff just for trophies and stuff like
that that's wasteful um if you're
hunting stuff to eat it i don't have a
problem with that
but other than that
and don't hurt predators for christ's
sake no
jesus christ
predators did not evolve to be preyed
upon that they don't reproduce their
reproductive numbers or yeah they're the
same nuts right
um like i said i don't
if i had to do it personally i'm not i
don't really like to kill any little
antelopes and the deer and [ __ ] you know
what i mean they they're in the rabbits
and squirrels squirrels you know birds
eat them
you know that's usually
birds eat them
hawks and [ __ ] birds of prey
so they have a very high reproductive
rate
but not cats
mountain lions don't have a high
reproductive rate well no they only have
neither rarely do things like neither
things like coyotes don't have a real
hyper reproductive rate and dingos
they're not really all that high they're
a generalist
neither are bears they don't have that
many cubs
so you're supposed to leave them alone
just leave them alone
i mean like i said you can't eat them
really i mean you can the meat's not
that good but the meat's not good it's
not that good so
you generally do not like serious
hunters do not
predator because you don't eat them and
like i said if you're not eating them
then
what's the point well some of them will
call predators but they pay to call
predators down in the african game you
know but then that's even still i kind
of feel like that's like dick slinging
and
to me it seems like pointless well
they're doing it in in in the african
countries because there isn't enough
land to s and prey animals to support
very many predators so some of the older
ones have to be called out and they'll
sell the culling rights out to [ __ ]
rich people who will come and say i want
to shoot a lion
you know
which yeah the land maybe can't support
that many lions because there's nothing
seriously why would you want to shoot a
lion though
they're shooting older lions and the
land can't support that many lions
because there isn't as many prey animals
because humans have encroached into
their i get that but like why like why
they just want a picture of themselves
why does that get your dick hard though
i mean maybe you should like go to
therapy about that
because
it depends on the what's your problem it
depends on the situation in the person
what's your problem some people just
want to kill one of everything
you know i mean i killed a lot of [ __ ]
but again what's your problem why like
why do you feel the need to do that
when it comes to african game it's
always rich guys always that's what i
mean so i kind of feel like there's uh
there's an aspect of inadequacy
um yeah i don't know i don't know yeah i
don't know i don't know because it it
depends on depends on the hunter some of
those guys are just they're [ __ ] they
want to have
hunting rights and they're also stuff
and i'm doing taxidermy
and they're paying
to do right but
like okay there's conservation i'm just
we're getting sidetracked i'm just
saying
what's the practical like look you're
not eating that
i think you do eat it but it's not very
good that's what i'm saying you're not
eating it you're not doing it because
you have to right um you're just you're
just killing
a part like a lion or whatever it is
you're just killing a predator
because you want dick slinging rights to
say that like i killed a lion i'm gonna
stuff it and put it in my [ __ ] parlor
yeah and everybody will come over and be
impressed so to me it seems like that's
some little dick [ __ ] that's some little
dick energy that's some little thick
energy i wouldn't do it that's not the
kind of my kind of thing that's what i'm
saying that's some little dick i have to
know what the that's some like
insecurity issues i wouldn't do it big
time
because why
do you feel the need
to go out and kill an animal that's done
nothing to you and that you can't you
can't eat it
it's not there's no practical there's
another use to you
why do you feel the need to do that
converse to [ __ ] killing big cats
yeah to me that's like that's some
little dick energy and i'm just
it's not in my instincts to kill big
cats
one of the things is that
those big cats that these guys are
paying to kill even though they're
culling them out of nature
not that particular cat that he's
killing but what's weird about those big
cats is that they make good pets
sure that we've been lied to a lot you
can have if you can afford to feed a
lion you can have a lion and it's a fun
pet
i've seen it on video mountain lions and
[ __ ] getting up in a bed with a dude
and really you have to understand that
the future of all these animals is as
either
zoo
specimens or pets
so we have to learn to live alongside
these creatures i'm fine with that and
really you could take these big cats and
make them domestic pets i am awesome
um well yeah if i could honestly if i if
i could afford to feed them right yeah
sure but uh i have a lot of these
animals that over the time i've realized
i've seen on video that are very
friendly we thought raccoons were mean
raccoons are real friendly if you but i
didn't know that
they are actually yeah they're real
friendly uh they make good pets but a
lot of these wild animals do make pretty
good pets as long as they have a
well you can talk some more i gotta pee
you gotta okay uh and also i need
another drink but wait till i get back
from pee
you're saying i'm on a roll
hold on
i'm trying to get up in here and see
what everybody's talking about cheryl
mcwood just shut up said what's up pete
probably missed the whole show you
missed like the first one third of the
show
uh tina says if you're raising chickens
you have to understand how nature works
you got to protect your food yeah
exactly
all right um
we're talking about chickens
and then tina says vegetarian is
sounding better and better to me now
we supposed to be in a little bit of
everything
um
let's see what we're talking about
the thing about
we live in an area here where you can
grow um
vegetables and fruits i'm planting a
bunch of cherries out there
and uh plant vegetables too
and uh
man
it'd be easy because i got enough land
to put chicken coop out there but they
just make so much goddamn noise
although having
eggs
because
12 chickens [ __ ] produce a lot of
eggs more eggs than [ __ ] me and jen
could eat
um
the hoa would not really [ __ ] be
[ __ ] cool about me having free-range
chickens out back there
so my friend uh
angel his little goth
chick that [ __ ] i probably showed
pictures of her
she's raising rabbits she's thinking
about moving out here
hurt her
her and her kin
and
angel's raising rabbits robbed rabbits
are a lot
cleaner and they're quiet
and they don't cost too much to [ __ ]
raise please don't make me kill anyone
the thing is though man it's like oh
you're gonna slaughter them they're so
cute
i'll kill them rabbits she's got them
and i says how do you kill me you just
cut the heads off or something she goes
no i got a piece of wood it's got a v
you put their [ __ ] head in there and
go pop you pop their [ __ ] little
necks like that absolutely not damn
absolutely not and i was like that's
kind of cold-blooded you know i could do
that to a chicken i could cut a
chicken's head off no problem but this i
don't think i could do that
i mean i could if i was starving yeah
otherwise no i could do it i cannot i
could i could shoot a wild rabbit no
problem but a [ __ ] rabbit that you've
raised you can just put it and break its
neck like that nope
i could probably cut its head off nope
or shoot it
but
i i'm like going i don't know i i told
i told angels
i said the system sounds good because
i've had rabbit rabbits really good
so that system sounds good very cost
effective but i don't know if i can
break a rabbit's neck every couple days
yeah no says i could cut a chicken's
head off a couple days because they make
so much noise they're stinky
and she is right because i took care of
[ __ ] dr matt's chickens
uh got so many damn chick eggs out of
chickens
[ __ ] that
the thing is though i've had other
people yeah i could do that too
because you get a lot of eggs the
problem is is that the hoa probably
allowed they make so much [ __ ] noise
and they [ __ ] on everything and yeah i
don't think i literally don't allow you
you gotta let them go you gotta let them
go so they can walk around and eat
everything and they they're a nuisance
and the situation the food situation
isn't bad enough yet
to where the the hoa is going to
tolerate [ __ ] chickens that's what i
mean you can still buy chicken at the
grocery store for christ's sake yeah
well there's a bunch of food in security
going on right now yeah but you know
oh my goodness thank you bryce
new zealand five dollars thank you very
much with a little
what is that a little fox this little
fox yeah a little fox
yeah
he's like please don't kill me yeah i
know
um honestly like i'll eat some meat
fishing and chicken if i had to kill it
myself i would absolutely be a
vegetarian i'm not doing that i don't
have a problem but raising it and
slaughtering it is like a little
especially if it's rabbits that's a warm
blooded mammal you know dumb
chickens
chickens are like little chickens yeah
i'm still like kind of chickens are a
little more like robots to be they're
just but still they still gotta eat i
mean they still seem like sentient
though so i'm not like
oh my god i just remembered i've been
watching this show if you guys haven't
uh
if you if if you guys weren't here the
last couple days i'm gonna watch this
show on to be i don't know where it
originated from but it's a true crime
show called bizarre murders
and one of the ones i watched the other
day was about a guy and he was like this
rednecky dude and he like lived in a
trailer
and one of his favorite things he well
he had like a bird and he had like all
it's a cat a dog he had like all these
he was like a big animal lover
and i kind of laughed because on the
show they mentioned
that every single animal that he adopted
he called them
he called them his pookies his boogies
yeah and i kind of like laughed because
pookie was in the room when i was
watching the show
and they kept saying pookie like on the
show and i was like they're talking
about you pookie and she was like
looking at me like oh my god they're
talking about me and it was like this
weirdest [ __ ] thing john says yeah
but rabbits have next to zero
nutritional value i don't know where
you're getting that man protein is
protein
rabbits are
i mean more it's it's more like it's
that that's that's probably better than
chicken uh
some more similar to like crusting
chicken and pork like i said all kinds
of nutritional if i had to choose
between oh we're gonna kill some like
cute-ass animals and it's like i'll just
eat like vegetables thanks yeah okay
beans
i'm okay with that i'm okay with that if
i had to kill the animal myself yeah no
i'm not doing that tina's [ __ ] trying
to get me to become a vegetarian you're
[ __ ] crazy
uh no i i couldn't uh go vegetarian not
on all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that i'm on now
he says uh
tila says
tell my dairy try vegetarian for a week
that's what i'm saying really good
but honestly i love it even without
thinking about it i think we've eaten
vegetarian for like a week or two at a
time well because we eat a lot of indian
food yeah and a lot of that is just
vegetarian like incidentally yeah so
sometimes we'll eat vegetarian for
several days in a row without even
really realizing but i'm i'm drinking a
lot of whey protein which is there and
that's animal cells
the whey protein so and then i'm eating
other pieces of meat and stuff little
[ __ ] bacon bits and [ __ ] little
things of damn sausage and
chicken and
so
i get it has to be high
protein my diet has to be high protein
with my [ __ ] training schedule but i
mean protein doesn't have to be meat
though either like you can get protein
in other please yeah yeah but you got to
look at the [ __ ] details uh [ __ ]
uh protein from like beans and rice and
legumes and [ __ ] like that it's very
high calorie legumes legumes legumes in
portuguese it's lagoons [ __ ] you have
to have
it uh to get enough protein
from vegetarian sources would increase
my [ __ ] calorie intake too much
so
i have to be
very high protein and very low calorie
and a lot of protein
because of all the drugs i'm on
if you want to call them drugs
in my training schedule so no you can't
you can't be
purely vegetarian you have to have a lot
of [ __ ] whey protein or animal
protein
or you'll just never gain any weight
you'll never synthesize the protein into
muscle tissue no need for me too says
tease the wife with here piggy piggy
and not cause she's the biggen
okay yeah but you'll get sore and you'll
never you'll never heal back up
that's
not not with what i do if you're a
normal person
yeah you could but you'd end up looking
like an indian
you know like somebody from india skinny
or you know an asian
and
no one wants to do that no
i'm [ __ ] jacked what are you talking
about
apex predator okay i eat you when i get
hungry
you try to eat me i eat you when i get
hungry [ __ ] i will [ __ ] you up
you should [ __ ] try to eat me i'll
eat your ass and then i'll [ __ ] you out
and eat you again yeah okay all right
now i'm way more [ __ ] up than you
would okay p pro she talked about p
protein p protein i looked at that
p protein is not bad the problem is is
the it's expensive
whey protein is cheaper
and uh
probably about the same in terms of
effectiveness but
uh p protein and it doesn't taste as
good peat protein's not that no it's
better just go with animal protein man
t
the best this has kind of been proven by
dudes that are on all kinds of anabolics
and guys that went to [ __ ] olympia
and [ __ ] actually built [ __ ]
fantastic [ __ ] bodies so these are
the extreme cases
and the extreme cases kind of prove
certain ideas the best protein is
[ __ ] seafood
it's very lean extremely high in [ __ ]
protein very low in calorie and it's got
a lot of iodine in it and [ __ ] [ __ ]
the best of seafood
but the problem is if you're in the
united states seafood is expensive
seafood's expensive
now that crab that i made the crab with
a k
that's [ __ ] pollock that's pretty
good protein it's like white fish it's
like white fish
it's pretty good it's just it's not very
versatile when it comes to cooking i
don't eat just to [ __ ] say well yeah
well i eat something now i eat because
i'm making a creation you know i'm a
[ __ ] cook so
you know and when this [ __ ] goes down
when this [ __ ] goes mad max as a
[ __ ] y'all are gonna be on the
menu i'm gonna eat y'all
that's right i'm gonna eat well that's
if i if i don't eat you first yeah i'm
gonna [ __ ] eat you talking about i'm
gonna go back to my viking [ __ ] roots
okay we're gonna go back to long pig
when people who cannot [ __ ] handle
their own [ __ ] business they can't
[ __ ] they can't do [ __ ] you're gonna
go on the menu i'm gonna eat you all
right you're gonna be delicious yeah
that's right i ain't losing any weight
okay i'm gonna [ __ ] gain protein it's
gonna be like from the viking days
okay
he's getting he's gonna be like i'm
gonna eat it okay look i got recipes
already worked up
it can be just like pork just gonna be
just like pork recipes well yeah
yeah it's gonna look pretty it's not
gonna look savage it's not not like
anything on a horror movie or anything
it's gonna be beautiful cuts
all [ __ ] and and i'm gonna have you
then your name is gonna be there and
everything gonna be like i'm making a
curry out of you tom curry
i'll give it like a vietnamese name it
kind of sounds like when this [ __ ] goes
mad max i'm [ __ ] ready
okay
and you assume that no one else is ready
oh yeah cheryl says after about 90 days
after about 90 days to maybe a year
depending on how how it goes down he
thinks that
he thinks that no one's gonna eat him
first oh hell no
you gotta sleep sometime [ __ ]
after after after about a year or so all
the people that are good at this [ __ ]
are gonna be here still we're gonna
still be around oh i don't need any
people who are not very good at this
[ __ ] they've been long gone i don't know
and i'm gonna be out here we're gonna be
out here in the country so it uh it's
gonna be a different situation
i gotta [ __ ] yeah okay i know exactly
how you talk how you want to i know
exactly
this is tom you need an instagram pro
cook profile i got an instagram
do you i got instagram yeah oh i didn't
even know that no i got an instagram why
is my drink empty right now oh [ __ ] you
want a drink okay yeah
i got an instagram shrimp regret's
awesome mmm
tommy grits yeah
yeah
delicious i'm just you know
i'm thinking about cannibalism right now
but yeah no
it's nothing okay so where was i
where was i
okay so there was this whole [ __ ]
situation we're getting back to the case
in case you forgot we were talking about
that
so this whole [ __ ] thing where people
thought well because the way the
jumpsuit looked
uh and the way the blood pattern was on
it
and uh there was some ultraviolet
photographs of the [ __ ] it's like uh the
forensic specialist who is from england
by the way not necessarily from
australia not that that's
you know casting too much i'm just
saying
um and he said well that looks like
somebody cut the baby's throat rather
than
an animal attacking the baby the blood
pattern wouldn't have been the same
now the media did not help during this
situation because
uh the media as generally happens in
this situation
is that they're gonna like print
whatever gets them the most uh well in
1980 whatever gets them the most people
buying their newspaper and nowadays most
clicks same uh
principle so back then they're gonna do
whatever causes the most outrage uh
whatever causes the most
people to buy their [ __ ]
so
newspapers started printing stuff like
well
we think that the chamberlain family
because they're seventh day adventists
which like i said were kind of like
not the most trust trustworthy like
religious sect in australia at the time
i mean we thought they were weirdos too
um like i said see our dr kellogg uh
episode for more information uh they are
weirdos but
they did kind of see them maybe even
more as weirdos in australia in 1980 so
they were kind of like oh well we're
gonna like jump from them being weirdos
to them being like an outright cult
um and they tried to make
a connection between
them the chamberlain family and their
seventh day adventist beliefs and they
tried to like connect it with
the jonestown massacre which we've done
a show about and which happened two
years prior
uh which was another offshoot christian
denomination again a weird cult thing so
they try to like hook it up with that so
there was that whole situation
um so a lot of
people started to speculate that maybe
azaria the baby
was sacrificed
some
reason
like i said
this is
this is early satanic panic but it's
still satanic panic because i kind of
feel like satanic panic started what
early 70s because that was when like all
the satanic horror movies started coming
out like the extra i don't think the
panic was
well the panic i think it was 80s that
was like mid to late 80s even into the
90s but there were precursors of it
because like i said going back to i kind
of feel like going back to like
rosemary's baby which was 1968
exorcist 1973
there were like some tendrils of it
floating around prior to that
so 1980
sure do you know pokemon hey poke
um so
so there was that so i kind of feel like
that kind of fueled the whole situation
too these people are of a religious
denomination that even though it's
christian
is
weird quote unquote
uh so we can cast them as a cult so they
must be like doing some sacrifice as
cults do so it was that kind of thing
so uh the narrative became
they sacrificed the baby
to
their cult
and then tried to make it seem like a
dingo had done it so there was that
um some people even said that lindy was
a witch there was that too like some
people brought that up as well
so uh at this point october 1st 1980
several months after the baby had
disappeared and the
clothing was found
the one of the detectives on the case
uh did a several hour long interview uh
stop it pokey interviewed both
oh my goodness she said don't tip the
furniture
okay my new couch
and stuff that i bought she's just kind
of like don't care
she's not care she's not tear up the
couch it's kind of like the little we
got like a little like table
storage
thing like a little thing that you brush
your feet on it's it's kind of like a
three-way thing
uh there's that but she loves to like
scratch on it whatever what are you
gonna do
so yeah so they do an interview separate
interviews with her
and with
michael chamberlain
now
it seemed kind of like friendly from the
outset
but
lindy
probably understandably
was very frustrated because it seemed
like look i told you [ __ ] what
happened
which she did to be fair
and everyone was kind of trying to like
maneuver the framework of the story into
like something else so she was getting
really like frustrated with the
situation just like look i already told
you what happened
um
and they weren't really listening to her
one thing that didn't help though and
i'm not saying this is her fault um i'm
just saying that one thing that didn't
help was that they were like well we
should hypnotize you
and then maybe you'll like remember the
details better
and she was like look um i don't do that
like that's not
uh part of her religious belief she did
not want to be hypnotized she kind of
felt like that was maybe i'm putting
words in her mouth but i kind of felt
like she thought that was maybe um
[Music]
i don't know like kind of like
paranormal or something that like wasn't
biblically allowed
so i mean her quote was
the church wouldn't allow it
and i wouldn't do it so seventh-day
adventists do not allow hypnotism
because they thought that was like some
[ __ ] like
psychic or paranormal [ __ ] which was
something they didn't allow
um
she also said further and i'm quoting
god slew saul for that
do you know saul and the witch of endor
so she would not allow herself to be
hypnotized
uh which to her was probably like a
religious stand to police uh seemed
suspicious but she didn't want to do it
so at this point they do uh the first of
three corners in quest like i said there
would be three inquests on this [ __ ]
actually four maybe now that i'm
thinking about it but this is the first
one
now this happened in october of 1980 uh
probably i think this was the first
uh inquest trial whatever that was live
on australian tv i could be wrong about
that but uh from what i heard that was
the case
now
so
what happened was they opened the
inquiry
uh in december of 1980.
and
at this point
this is what's [ __ ] up
the coroner
at the time i kind of feel like this is
one of the things it's not the only
thing but it was one of the things that
kind of like opened this up
the coroner says
look
i think that a that a dingo did take the
baby
but the coroner then like uh introduced
some uncertainty by saying
that he thought
that after the dingo took the baby
that somebody
who he did not name somebody unknown
like disposed of the remains because
they never did find the body they still
have not to this day
eat
well duh obviously it's an animal come
on
but the fact that he said okay yeah i
believe that a dingo took the kid i
don't believe that the parents killed
the kid
but after the dingo took the kid
he's positing maybe or the implication
being that he thought that dingo took
the kid and left it somewhere and then
the parents
or somebody then pick the baby like
disposed of it which
why but okay no
so the fact that he's that he left it
open for that
um i don't think that was the only thing
but that was one of the things that
caused
the [ __ ] brouhaha that followed
um
he did admit though that he's like look
i don't really see any motive for why
these parents would kill their kid
because honestly
uh
the chamberlains
they had two boys one of them was four
one of them six
uh evidently from everything oh hi
pookie look at her she's like yep i'm on
tv
from everything that i could discern
uh they'd had two boys
and lindy really really wanted a girl
and so the fact that she got pregnant
and then she gave birth to a girl
finally azaria she was super super
jazzed about it so i don't really see
why nine weeks after the girl was born
she would kill the baby i mean that
really doesn't make any sense to me
but okay uh whatever so i kind of feel
like
there there's a whole thing there i
don't really know why she would do that
but and even the the prosecutors were
like struggling to find like a motive
other than oh they were from a weird
religious denomination so it must have
been like a weird cult sacrifice that
was kind of like all they could come up
with like i said satanism seventh-day
adventist is not some weird culture
that's not i mean you know we're all
over this like i said we talked about
them a little bit when we talked we did
the dr kellogg show they do have they do
have some weird beliefs sure
but a lot of a lot of christian
denominations have weird beliefs
and no one's calling them a cult or
saying they're sacrificing babies i kind
of feel like everybody just was out for
them because they didn't want
to think that just
it was just a random
like a dog took the baby and ate it yeah
i mean that's [ __ ] up that would be
[ __ ] up if that happened to your baby
nobody wants to think about that
happening so i kind of feel like well we
we need to blame somebody
no one is thinking that specifically
but i think deep down people are
thinking that everybody wants somebody
to like blame for something which is
some [ __ ] yeah that's exactly what it
was
so
another thing um so like i said they
kind of had that whole thing and some
people were like well
we don't understand like we didn't find
because uh one thing lindy
she kept saying
okay because one of the big things that
came up in the trial was that well we
didn't find a dingo saliva
on
the jumpsuit that they found which had
like a [ __ ] ton of blood on it and lindy
kept saying well the baby had a little
jacket on she called it a matinee jacket
i guess in our parlor i don't know it's
like a little cardigan like a little
sweater
um that she always put on over the
baby's little jumpsuit like a little
sing singlet or whatever
she's like and she kept insisting like
look the baby had this little jacket on
that was like it was knitted and it was
white and it had like little
lemon
kind of trim on it and the fact that
they didn't find that for a really long
time they were like oh well she must
have just made that up
because that would explain why we didn't
find any dingo saliva on the jumpsuit
that we found
so
that was like a big thing for many many
years even though she kept insisting
look the baby had a little jacket on
and that was
another thing that kind of like cast a
lot of doubt in people's minds because
it's like when they found the um the
jumpsuit that the baby had been wearing
that had blood all over it and like i
said i've seen pictures don't google it
if you don't want to be upset because
it's upsetting looking
but they did find that
and when it was found it was um either
that or like the thing that was
underneath was inside out
so there was like a lot of um
speculation about well would a dingo
actually like a dog actually be able to
drag the baby out of its clothing so
that the clothing would be found inside
out
um which was a
kind of a point of evidence that was
used against her a lot of times and the
fact like i said that they never found
the little jacket that she
said the baby had been wearing which
like i said was why they didn't find any
dingo saliva on any of the clothing so
that was kind of another thing but uh
we'll get it a little bit later because
that uh does factor in later on
now uh so as i said i think this was the
first trial or inquest or whatever that
was uh uh
you know live on australian tv
now uh basically
what
what the like i said this was really
weird because the coroner said well i
don't think that the family was
responsible for her death but
on this by the same token i think that
somebody like a person
disposed of the body because they never
did find it which left [ __ ] open
wide to all kind of like crazy
shenanigans like i said i kind of feel
like there was some [ __ ] too with the
whole dude that found like the
ultraviolet stuff and he's like oh i
found handprints on the stuff and
the thing on the neck of the
jumpsuit looked like it had been cut
with scissors and not with teeth
so
there was a contingent already that were
primed to blame her
for the murder
and they just used that to
kind of like push the [ __ ] forward
so at that point because the [ __ ] was
open-ended
uh they decided they were going to like
go after her as like a murder
investigation because they thought that
maybe something else was going on and
she was just blaming it on a [ __ ]
dingo
now uh in september of 1981
a bunch of cops
came in and did a huge four and a half
hour search
of the chamberlain's house
uh looking first any kind of evidence
that would suggest that they had killed
their baby for whatever reason
and one of the things too that they said
during the thing was like well we don't
need a reason uh we just need proof that
they did it we don't give a [ __ ] like
what the motive was they basically they
didn't say that exactly but that's like
what they meant
so did they did this big search
uh they found
they seized over 300 items
um
being like a bunch of the baby's clothes
a pair of scissors but that was one big
thing they thought that
the cut on the clothing looked like it
came from scissors rather than like a
dingo's teeth that was a big thing so
they uh
took the scissors and they took a bunch
of other [ __ ] from the house
they also
searched the yellow
tirana hatchback
which the family had driven to
uluru
uh which would become a massive massive
point of contention
so uh
at this point it's funny because
again and i don't think like i said i'm
not blaming her but i do think that like
her
laissez-faire like sarcastic kind of
attitude like i said i'm not blaming her
because i probably would have done the
same thing
um
she was very like sardonic and i don't
think that helped her case very much
because when they told her look this
dude uh example like james cameron from
england examined the baby's clothes and
said that probably a dingo didn't do it
lindy says she's the mom and she says
quote
i didn't know there were any dingo
experts in london
she says
which like i said
probably didn't endear her but i get it
because that's probably what i would
have said as well so
i'm not [ __ ] on her because that's
obviously what i would have said and
she's right um who are you to come here
and like say you know everything about
dingos you're not even from here so okay
so there was that
um
yeah so there was all kind of like legal
[ __ ] november 1981 like this uh the
chief minister comes in and he's he was
the attorney general for the northern
territory at the time he wanted to quash
the findings of the first inquest
uh based on some newly discovered
evidence
uh but then
there was a whole thing where they
wanted to open a second inquest because
of some
let's call it alleged evidence that had
been found in their car because like i
said they
uh you know impounded their car and they
searched it and they apparently found
all kind of like incriminating evidence
in there
but
yeah we'll see how that goes
so they open up a second inquest
in december of 1981
now
the dude
that uh
was
assisting the coroner at the time the
barrister
he didn't really make much of a secret
of the fact
that even from the opening of this
inquest that he was pretty sure
that the sequence of events
was that lindy the mom
had taken the baby
for whatever reason
to
the campsite
and then had taken her
to the car
which was parked however far away from
the campsite i'm not entirely sure but
had taken her to the car
had slit the baby's throat
and then put her briefly in a camera bag
that they had in the car
and then later like took her out and
buried her someplace else and then ran
back to the campsite and said oh my god
a dingo took the baby that was like his
sequence of events
even though gotta say
not consistent with the witness
accounts of the evening because there
were several other people at the
campsite at the time
um but you know we'll get into that
so he kind of like thought that was the
uh
you know the sequence of events that was
the way he was coming at it
he thought that the
little girl the baby had been killed
with a pair of scissors have been you
know threaded and slit he's like oh my
god there's blood
all over this car
oh my goodness
that was another thing too
um
allegedly allegedly
some forensic evidence uh fetal
hemoglobin if you want to call it that
had been called have been like found all
over this car
uh during this
second investigation
now
i don't know how much i want to get into
this because i kind of feel like this
i don't know this just goes to show if
you already have a narrative in your
mind and you're just like looking for
stuff like back up the nerds that you
already have in your mind
then
uh some bad [ __ ] can happen because
uh they wanted to find
baby blood essentially fetal hemoglobin
which is in uh baby blood up till about
six months although it can
uh
apparently as far as i could discern
uh does still exist in adults to a
terribly terribly small degree
but they thought oh my god there's fetal
hemoglobin all over this car and that is
consistent with um you know a baby's
neck being slit with a pair of scissors
and so obviously that means that the mom
slashed the baby's throat in the car
and then
put the baby in the bag and then carried
it somewhere else to like bury it and we
don't know where that is
so when they did the second inquest most
of the questions that they asked lindy
uh involved something like did you
notice any blood staining inside outside
you know or were there
how much time did you take cleaning
blood off the seats it was all that kind
of like questioning they were trying to
like get her on it
and
you know as as far as i know she was
just kind of like i i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about but
whatever
um so they bring in this other biologist
named joy cule
and she said again that she found fetal
hemoglobin uh between the passenger you
know beneath the uh passenger seat and
they said that they found some like kind
of splashed on the dashboard and like
some other places too so that seemed to
like point to
oh my god this is really like a murder
like the baby was killed in the car and
then you know taken elsewhere so there
was that
um this blood evidence was apparently so
persuasive that a lot of people uh
including like the judge and a lot of
the jurors like bought into it
so at this point lindy chamberlain the
mom of this baby gets charged with
murder uh and michael the dad uh gets
charged as an accessory they kind of
like figured that well
i don't know if he like was in on the
plan to like murder the baby but he knew
about it afterward like helped cover it
up so again accessory after the fact now
they never did find the body
uh again there was no motive other than
uh some motives that some newspapers
cooked up about well they're in
their seventh-day adventists so
obviously they're a cult so
cult sacrifice babies
qed i guess that was the extent of the
thinking on that
uh so there was that
and uh so they did that
so they opened the uh the prosecution
of lindy
who was pregnant again by this point
um
this was in
september of 1982.
now
from the very beginning of this
second trial or the second inquest
uh the prosecution is basically like
look um
this mom like she cut the baby's throat
in the car
um
we don't even give a [ __ ] what the
motive is we just know that somebody
murdered this baby and we think that
it's lindy chamberlain and that's what
we're going to prove we don't have to
prove a motive
because there might not be one they just
wanted to prove the fact of it
so they did that
and they said that the whole
dingo story was quote unquote a fanciful
lie calculated to conceal the truth so
there was that
now the weird thing about it though was
that the prosecution
brings up a lot of witnesses that were
other campers
that were there at the time that the
baby disappeared
and
most of these campers their stories
more corroborated lindy's
uh you know
thing about what had happened
they were like look um we were all
sitting around the barbecue and then we
all heard a baby crying
like in alarm and then like that got cut
off quickly
and then lindy
got up and was like oh [ __ ] what's that
and like took off to see what it was
it's like so we don't really know like
when she took off and like killed this
baby and like we didn't know where she
was because everybody heard the baby
crying and honestly like when
the prosecution said that the baby was
already dead
because they posited
that lindy
had taken the baby to the car
killed the baby like slit the baby's
throat
and then took it somewhere and like
buried it and then came back it's like
oh my god a dingo got my baby and then
uh you know made everybody look for it
even though she already buried the baby
and most of the people the campfire was
like yeah that's not how that could have
happened because like i said they heard
the baby crying like after
they said that that could have happened
but okay
so there was that
so as i said most of the people that
were there at the campsite um
even though they were brought up as
prosecution witnesses they kind of like
lean more toward the defense
in the fact that we don't know when she
would have like killed the baby because
we heard the baby crying and she just
like jumped up and was like oh my god
what the [ __ ] is that
you know the baby's crying so she went
to check on her so there was that whole
situation
now uh yeah now
so there was that whole situation and
then
uh there was another guy like uh sally
who was the
woman like one of the
the woman of the couple that was another
couple that was staying there camping at
the same time uh there was a guy named
greg who's her husband
and uh they asked him
he was supposedly a witness for the
prosecution
but then when they were doing like
examination and they asked him
they said well didn't you see
the chamberlain family like cleaning
blood out of their car
um and the dude was like no
i don't i don't really know what you're
talking about it's like look it happened
just like they said i don't know why
you're like asking me these questions
um he's like if they had gone off to
like kill the baby or clean their car
out i'm sure everybody would have
noticed because we were all just kind of
like sitting around having a barbecue
like you do
so there's that
uh one of the other witnesses that was
there at the campsite uh said that she
had heard lindy say
the dingo's got my baby
five or ten minutes after she heard a
dingo growl she said she actually did
hear a dingo growling
uh at the campsite so
there was that as well
and also this witness said that earlier
a dinko had come into the campsite and
grabbed her 12 year old daughter's arm
and tried to drag her away
so
there's that also like i said several
people had seen dingoes are on the
campsite earlier this witness said that
uh it grabbed her 12 year old daughter
by the arm which
12 year olds a lot bigger than a baby
now one of the things though
that i think and i think i brought this
up before but
this is one of the things that
probably turned the media and the public
against them was that they didn't react
the way people perceive that you
should react if your baby gets eaten by
an animal
um
they seemed a little bit
i don't know the word i want to use but
they seemed like not emotional enough
but i kind of feel like you can't really
win in that situation
because you come off as
not emotional enough everybody's gonna
freak out about that but if you're too
emotional
everybody's gonna freak about freak out
about that because they think you're
like faking it or you're trying to like
overdo it for
attention or whatever so i kind of feel
like however you react it's not right
you know what i'm saying
um
because as i said grieving nobody knows
how they're gonna react in a situation
where
the unthinkable happens your [ __ ]
baby
is taken away by an animal and eaten
you don't know how you're gonna react
you can think you know
but until that actually happens to you
you will have no idea how you're gonna
and honestly nobody has any idea how
they're gonna react in any kind of
situation that you don't
that you've never experienced
so the fact that other people
judge other people's reactions like oh
you're not you're too emotional or
you're not emotional enough
and that means one thing or the other
that's problematic it's problematic
because
as i said you're not in that situation
you don't know how you're going to react
you don't know how other people react
everybody reacts differently to things
some people change like some people like
overreact some people under react some
people shut down some people [ __ ]
freeze some people [ __ ] flip out and
you don't and honestly unless you're in
that situation yourself
you don't really know how you're gonna
react so
i don't think that's a good way of
um
kind of
assigning
guilt or innocence to somebody
the way they react to a situation like
that because everybody reacts
differently and
you don't know how you're going to react
like i said most people will not
thankfully will not experience their
baby being taken away by an animal and
eaten
and i have no idea how i would react in
that situation
so i'm not gonna like
get on their case about oh they weren't
emotional enough
like that means they did something that
doesn't mean anything that just means
that that's them
and that's how they're dealing with it
it doesn't
mean anything necessarily
but uh but yeah so the fact that she
wasn't
i guess
[ __ ] screaming and crying but like i
said if she had done that then they
would find some reason to like [ __ ]
[ __ ] on that because you can't win
uh so there was that and then the fact
that michael had said some weird [ __ ]
like oh she's probably dead by now and
like didn't even want to look for her
was seen as like weird by people uh
because they were like well he reacted
like that because he knew that uh you
know it was this big plan and he already
knew she was dead and so he didn't like
bother with it but like i said
what are you gonna do
um
so
basically
okay so the thing about it they brought
up because
the second inquest hinged so much on
this alleged
blood that they found in the
chamberlain's car
so they did kind of bring up well they
had picked up this hitchhiker
who had been bleeding
and they wanted to like kind of you know
the defense like wanted to say oh well
maybe that was that but the thing about
it is that much later
when they did another investigation of
this i just want to like bring this up
right now
the whole fetal hemoglobin thing which i
kind of feel like was one of the main
things that convicted them maybe
um
i have to say like the forensic evidence
this was 1980 like early 1980s forensic
science you know better than
before but still not that great
um
i feel like maybe not as uh
stringent as they would have liked it to
be and i do kind of feel like that they
already had an idea in their head what
they wanted to find
and they were like looking for that
because
the fact that they found quote unquote
fetal hemoglobin
um
there's a lot of problems with that uh
one thing you have fetal hemoglobin
if you're what a baby and you're like up
to six months old okay fine
but
the fact is that you can find fetal
hemoglobin it's not just from blood you
can find it in snot you can find it in
the vomit as far as it like other things
that are baby related uh because you
know babies snot and throw up all over
everything so there's that
and uh also
you it's found in other things and
honestly when they did a another
analysis of the car later on
they found that some of the [ __ ] was
from
[Music]
uh a sort of paint or an emulsion that
had been sprayed on the dashboard when
the car had been being manufactured in
the 1970s because it was chemically
very similar
so
again um later they found that like all
the quote unquote blood evidence they
found in the car
not necessarily blood uh or it didn't
necessarily have to be uh could have
easily come from other sources
so i kind of feel like that was what
they were hinging the whole [ __ ] on and
it really didn't like work out the way
they wanted but this is like way later
too late for
you know her for her not to have spent
like several years in prison
so uh so basically it's kind of like
yeah so you had all these [ __ ] people
coming up saying
all this blood yeah it's like oh a dog
couldn't done this and i like i got into
that a little bit too
and it was just this whole
i don't know i kind of feel like she was
kind of getting railroaded because
the the authorities the crowns case at
that point had turned toward her
uh and at that point
anything that came up was gonna be seen
as like evidence against or toward her
guilt
right
so
even all of the forensic evidence which
in reality was kind of could go one way
or the other i think they were kind of
like pushing it toward it being blood
even though later on
in a more like objective standpoint
it probably was not or it might not have
been
so there was that too
again i think they brought up too that
oh dingos don't usually attack humans
but
to their credit the defense did bring up
in this inquest
uh in this trial
that
dingoes absolutely they brought up a
bunch of other cases where dingoes had
attacked humans
uh there had been two dozen attacks uh
by dingos on humans
uh in this at this particular time uh
some most of them not fatal most of them
on children
a couple of them are adults though
and
so they did kind of bring that up to
their credit as i said
uh but
there was a whole thing where it's like
oh well
a baby's head couldn't fit into the
mouth of a dingo there was this whole
kind of thing we brought this whole [ __ ]
up earlier but the stupid thing was that
the defense
then countered that
wisely
with a photo of a dingo
and it had a baby doll
in its mouth
with the head in its mouth
easily and it was like carrying the baby
leg around
and uh even so
i just kind of feel like people didn't
really want to like buy it even though
they saw like the photos in front of
their face so there was that
uh again you have james cameron not the
director but a forensic scientist
uh bringing up some [ __ ] about
uh yeah the baby's uh throat was cut
because there's this notch in the
clothing
that was not from a tooth that was from
a cutting instrument so there was that
and i kind of feel like that was
probably given more weight than it
probably should have been
uh and he gave like the ultraviolet
thing and the stupid thing was that he
said oh these are like handprints bloody
handprints like on the clothing
but uh the defense brought up
when they brought uh lindy on the stand
and she held her hand up next to the
alleged
handprints
uh suddenly didn't really look so much
like a handprint anymore
so there was that as well
now interestingly so
lindy gets called to the stand
on the defense
and she's basically again um
she her whole thing was like she had a
jacket on because a lot of the thing was
like well how could the
dingo have turned these clothing inside
out why is there
on the clothing that we found why is
there no dingo saliva why is there no
this that and the other because they did
test for that
uh they did find some dog hairs i will
say like on the clothing and in the tent
but apparently that wasn't enough and
they were like oh well there's no dingo
saliva on the
on the uh onesie that we found so
obviously that means that dingo didn't
eat her
and you know where's the body we didn't
find any bones we didn't find any
anything
now she says well the reason there was
no saliva was because she had like a
little they called a matinee jacket it's
like a little cardigan she got like a
little sweater that's a little sweater
on now they didn't find the sweater so
for a long time they thought she was
just making it up
and but she was like look that's why
there's no dingos but other she had a
little jacket on i don't know where the
jacket is i'm not a dingo you know i
didn't do this [ __ ] but
that's probably why there's no [ __ ]
spit on the clothing that you found so
there was that but they didn't believe
her uh they thought she'd made up that
whole [ __ ]
uh but yeah she said it was a little
bite
jacket with a little
yellow colored uh edge on it
um so there was that and uh yeah so they
also kind of like poked holes in her
story about seeing a dingo in the
vicinity of the family tent thinking she
was trying to like set up the [ __ ]
story
and uh she's like well how come there
wasn't like blood all over the inside of
the tent how come there wasn't that this
that in the other and
she's like look i don't i'm not a dingo
i don't you know i don't know i'm not
speculating on that kind of stuff like i
said she kind of like did as best as she
could in this uh situation
um
and they were really kind of like
hostile toward her from the jump gotta
say
and uh
again it was just i don't know it was
like a whole thing
so i'm gonna let me skip through here
because i kind of talked about all this
now the defense did come forward
and they had a dingo expert called les
harris
and he said
uh what a dingo would do generally um
with a prey the size of the baby
which is about a 10 pound baby nine
weeks old
uh it would quote make seizure which
would be of the entire head and it would
close its jaws sufficiently to render
the mammal immobile
and then it would kind of like shake it
to break the neck and then it would drag
it back to wherever it was going and
then it would like eat it later so
that's kind of like what he was saying
um he said yeah it's not gonna like hang
around with the prey that it killed um
it wouldn't produce that much blood
because it was trying to again like
break the neck just immobilize it so we
could get it to where it could eat it
and that's what it would do
uh he also said that the teeth of the
dingo would very easily
tear through a material as tough as like
a seat belt or something like that so he
didn't really see any problem with it
you know tearing through clothing or
anything like that
um
and he also said
he also brought up at the trial to his
credit
that he had personally
seen a dingo
being given a bundle of meat that was
wrapped up in paper
and he said dingoes are very neat eaters
if you give them something wrapped up in
paper they will very carefully
take the [ __ ] out of the paper and then
eat it they won't like tear the paper up
so because i kind of feel like that was
a point of contention
that
the onesie that they found that the baby
had been wearing
was
not all that torn up the diaper was but
the if you see pictures of the onesie
that the baby was wearing it's very
bloody
but it's not torn it was kind of like
turned inside out but it was like still
in one piece so a lot of people were
like well obviously like a wild animal
would have done that because it would
have just like torn the [ __ ] up but this
guy said no
that dingoes would
if the meat was in a wrapper
it would actually very neatly
kind of pull the wrapper aside and then
eat the meat
and rather than like tearing the wrapper
up so he tried to like show
that that's what he would do
so you know so there was that he did try
um unfortunately
it was uh really not all that uh
effective because
what ended up happening
was that
lindy chamberlain
uh
was ultimately sentenced to
a life sentence
for the murder of her daughter
michael the husband
uh was given accessory after the fact
although he was given a suspended
sentence
because he's just the dad there's just
no goddamn evidence for he got a
suspended sentence for 18 months and
like i said um
yeah and this is kind of one of those
cases like i said it's bad enough that
this poor [ __ ] family lost the baby
got the baby taken away like eaten by an
animal which i can't even imagine how
[ __ ] horrible that would be and then
like to get blamed for it like and
especially her like that's her
baby yeah she just had that and she was
like super happy about this baby she had
wanted a daughter yeah she had two boys
already and she had wanted a little girl
and she finally got one she was nine
weeks old
the baby gets carried away by a wild
animal and then all of a sudden she's
[ __ ] hitler and there's no evidence
of foul play ah
i can't imagine what that would be like
i would just oh my god i would just want
to kill everybody if that happened
uh what ended up happening
so she got convicted
amazingly
uh it was 1980 l like early 1980s she
gets convicted
and she gets a life
sentence
even though she there was no motive
not really any evidence but like i said
everybody kind of wanted to think she
was like some weirdo that sacrificed the
baby even though there's no [ __ ] idea
well as i mentioned earlier yeah they
found out later once they weren't like
blinded by
wanting her to be a murderess yeah uh
was that the [ __ ] they found in the car
wasn't even blood it wasn't blood
you know what i mean
they found out later yeah they just
wanted it to be because they wanted her
to be guilty
so
[ __ ] evil [ __ ] this [ __ ]
happened later what ended up happening
so there were like several [ __ ]
things she ends up going to prison they
gave her a life sentence okay like like
i said michael the husband he was
accessory after the fact they didn't
think that he was like in on it from the
beginning but like once it happened he
was like okay i'm down and he helped her
cover it up like i said the whole story
was that
they wanted to sacrifice the baby for
some reason because they were
seventh-day adventists therefore
satanists whatever the [ __ ] so they were
like okay well they took she took the
baby to the car
and slashed the baby's throat for some
reason put her in a camera bag
um for some reason which they did admit
well they have with this camera bag and
they said oh we put our clothes in there
sometimes because it was a bag and it
was available
um so they said yeah they put her body
and then later
they took the body and like buried it
someplace and we haven't been able to
find it yet
like i said they've never found the body
uh to this day
so uh so yeah lindy got uh [ __ ]
convicted
and she got a life sentence
in [ __ ] prison
now
she probably would have been in there
forever
if it wasn't for a very strange uh now i
will say that like the jury was kind of
like divided but they don't have a thing
i guess in australia where
i guess in the u.s in most cases you
kind of have to have like um you know
everybody has to agree like if you don't
it's a hung jury and they have to do
like a retrial but in australia i guess
it's i don't know if this is still the
case but back in the 80s i guess it was
like a majority
um like i said i don't think it works
the same in the us but uh similar
so there was that
uh so she had like a bunch of appeals
and stuff but you know they didn't work
out
and uh basically as time went on so
she's in prison she goes to [ __ ]
prison
and as time goes on and people kind of
come to their senses i want to say
um people started like signing petitions
and saying like oh maybe she didn't do
it so there was like this whole like
kind of free lindy movement uh at that
point
so there was that
and uh basically after the more
cogent scientific evidence came out that
like all the quote-unquote blood they
found in this car was not actually
necessarily blood it could have been
from
uh a zillion other things it could have
been from like a baby sneezing it could
have been from like the [ __ ] emulsion
from the paint like from when the car
was made it could have been from a
million other sources
so
a lot of the public not all of them
because there's still like about half of
them that still think she's guilty
but
there was a whole thing it's like yeah
you need to let her out because she
didn't do that [ __ ]
so uh there was that
now interestingly nothing really came to
a head until 1986 and this was a total
[ __ ] fluke that this happened it's
very sad
so there was a hiker he was english and
his name's david brett
and he was hiking on uluru ayers rock
and he fell
from the rock when he was hiking and he
died
now they didn't find him they didn't
find his body for i think it was like a
week maybe more than more than that
seven eight days something like that
so they found his body like later on
now the area where they found his body
coincidentally
was an area of a whole bunch of like
dingo
layers
also where they found his body
they also found
the
jacket that the baby had been wearing
yeah when she was taken what's that tell
you which everybody said didn't exist
yeah they found it and it was covered
with [ __ ] blood just like she said
the whole [ __ ] time the baby had a
jacket on that's why you're not finding
any dingus what's the chances of them
killing the baby they found it what's
the chances of them killing the baby and
taking the jacket off the baby and then
taking it to a dingo layer and
hiding it
and then not telling people later on
it's like well you might want to check
over there maybe you might find the
jacket no i missed the [ __ ] well they
didn't know where the jack well because
the dingo took the baby back to its cave
and ate it presumably but the saying is
is that there was no way they would have
set that up there's no way they could
have said that absolutely not absolutely
if they did set it up they would say why
don't you go look over there maybe you
maybe you'll find something
so this it wasn't a setup they found the
layer and look there's that [ __ ]
jacket
that means that the dog's here
years ago
yeah they found it like by like the the
mouth of a cave where dingo's yeah the
dingo got the baby yep
obviously if that was planted they would
have [ __ ] said something they would
have said
it's out there somewhere the whole time
she said yeah the baby had a little
jacket on and honestly the authorities
they didn't find the jack they found the
baby's other clothing they found the
diaper and they found the the onesie the
little thing that the baby had been
wearing she was not glad she was
innocent of this crap
[ __ ] animal took the baby
of course and she was in prison of
course for how long
three or four years yeah still
i mean three or four years too long and
after she got out and after she got out
half the population still thought she
did it it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and like how dumb people are and see
like people like
we got somebody that in the comments
from from australia and said people
still spit at her in the [ __ ] because
she's still alive
she's still alive
uh and people can stop her in the street
people are she can do that [ __ ] leave
that [ __ ] alone just wait
they're gonna say that that [ __ ]
jacket was planted if they were planted
they would have called attention to the
plant
they didn't find that until years later
which means that it was not planted the
[ __ ] dog the dingoes took that and
she was just kind of i [ __ ] told you
the baby had a little jacket on
and they didn't believe her they found
it
1986 and they wouldn't have found it if
that dude hadn't like fallen off like
that hiker randomly hadn't fallen off
and died and they were looking for his
body
while they were looking for his body
they found that this is part of the
problem god damn it they give that
basically kids they give these people
the in these courts and these
governments they give them [ __ ]
qualified immunity so you can't sue them
for the stupid [ __ ] that they do
if you
got rid of their qualified immunity
they'd be [ __ ] a lot less apt to send
a [ __ ] from prison to prison for
something that they can't prove
that's a lot of it right there i mean to
be honest i'm a big advocate of look if
you can't prove that [ __ ] absolutely you
got it especially nowadays now that they
have dna yeah if you don't have dna for
that [ __ ] then you gotta walk i hate it
because some of those people might be
serial killer i don't know but honestly
just to be on the safe side
you should probably just let them go
because you don't [ __ ] know you don't
know
and all kind of weird [ __ ] can happen
like i said this situation
it just i don't know it makes me so sad
because it makes me so sad for that
family because how
[ __ ] up would that be to have your
baby that baby was nine weeks old
to have that baby taken away and eaten
by a wild animal
and then have your whole life ruined
because everybody thought you did it
you were in prison even after you got
out of prison
half the people still think you did it
so you can't actually ever go anywhere
yeah without everybody knowing who you
are because you're famous now and
thinking oh you killed that baby tina
said in the movie the tabloids are
analyzing their horoscopes and [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] crazy they were it's
like uh
you can work these stupid [ __ ]
up the average person has a [ __ ] iq
of a hundred that's dumb that's dumb as
[ __ ] because i mean half of them are
dumber than that you can [ __ ] work
them up into a damn frenzy especially if
you got the media on your side and a
couple of [ __ ] that call themselves
[ __ ] judges or lawyers and they can
[ __ ] [ __ ] you up that's why i don't
believe anything i believe i mean please
as as it is please just think of like
things for a second
and honestly i'm kind of one of those
people i'm very circumspect we're still
in the medieval era it's still the media
well people are still kind of idiots
they're the same thing um
you just honestly you just have to be
very cognizant of human weaknesses yeah
um
and of human biases
you just really i honestly i think the
best way to go about this
is teach people about
the way that human thinking goes wrong
you know what i'm saying i'm just saying
you should be aware if you're aware
then it's less likely that it happens to
you because honestly
you just have to step back and think for
a second before you jump into the frame
before you jump onto
social media and like castigate that
person
think for a second it's like how likely
is it that this is true
um you really need to and honestly even
if it is true
do you really want to jump into that
fray
and then later find out that it's not
true and then you're gonna like look
like an idiot well a lot of it's [ __ ]
tribalism and confirmation bias well
yeah they found they found a woman who
had some religion that they didn't that
most people didn't have so they used
that against her too anything because
anything that's different
about you can be used against you well
that's what i'm saying and it's like
that's one thing that kind of like
bothers me about
um and honestly i'm gonna say that's one
of the kind of reasons that i like that
bizarre murder show is that
the guy that's on there he's kind of
like the he's not the narrator but he's
kind of like the main guy that's talking
about he was in the fbi for a long time
and one of the things that he kind of
like
uh sort of
you know highlights on the show
is that you can't really come into stuff
like even though
yes this person looks like the most
common you know the most obvious suspect
or something like that he's like you
can't
jump into that you can't make everything
fit into that narrative you really can't
do that you really have to just sit back
and be very objective and just be like
what does the evidence say
yes i know that this person
looks like they did it but that doesn't
always mean that they did do it you know
what i'm saying so you really have to be
very very careful
because
you could be ruining an innocent
person's life
which definitely did happen in this
situation and that's like
and you've compounded it because
um
like i said she lost a [ __ ] baby in a
horrific horrific way getting muscle
cramps and then to be oh my goodness
damn wow
are you trying to get attention off
camera
but to lose a baby in that horrific
a way
and then to have that grief compounded
by everybody
like half the people in the country
maybe have to be on the world
thinking that you did it
i mean i can't
god that must be like the [ __ ] worst
thing ever like you can't go to
everybody knows you
everybody knows your face you can't go
anywhere but he knows your name you're
in all the [ __ ] papers
everybody's like baby killer this that
and the other and it's like oh my god
that must be [ __ ] horrible and it's
like you can't even like process
the grief
of losing your child in this horrible
horrible accident and everybody thinks
you did it that's why
and like i said that's that's why it's
complicated because look it's like i
write about true crime i read about true
crime like all the time
and i will say that like when babies
children stuff like that when they
disappear
usually not always statistically it is
more likely
that it is a family member that did
something to them but not always so you
can't assume that statistically it's
more likely but i don't think it's
uh i don't think it behooves anyone to
just jump into the fray and say oh well
the parents obviously had something to
do because honestly we when we talked
about this we talked about the battle of
mccann case um that little girl that
disappeared from her room like the
british couple and they were vacationing
in portugal and their
kid disappeared
and
i honestly don't think their parents had
anything to do with it and i think that
like all these elaborate conspiracy
theories that people have come up with
to
uh kind of like impugn their parents are
really um
shitty and i don't think have any basis
in reality i mean
there are shitty people in the world
that would just randomly kidnap a kid
and i can't imagine
having your kid kidnapped and then
having the
the grief compounded by everybody in the
world thinking that you had something to
do with it even though we absolutely did
not
so
i'm very like
circumspect about
jumping on a bandwagon to like jump on
so much [ __ ] look if i think somebody
actually did something like a serial
killer oh yeah i'm i'm all about that
yeah cut their dick off whatever but
until you know for sure
that that person did that
no
lay off that [ __ ] you don't know you
don't know if that person did that even
if it looks like they did that
that's not necessarily the case there
could be all kind of like crazy [ __ ]
happening so there was that and honestly
it's it freaks me out that
lindy chamberlain
if that dude if that english hiker
hadn't fallen off that [ __ ] rock
in 1986
and died
and they were looking for his body and
then they happened to find that little
that baby's jacket
she might still be in prison
not gonna lie
and she might still be sitting there in
prison being like look i didn't do
anything and here i am in prison my
whole [ __ ] entire life is ruined
that's a person's whole entire life
that's ruined
um so she did get out
now
they did give them eventually uh it took
them a while i think it was honestly
2012
before they changed the death
certificate
to say
death by dingo so
at least they acknowledged that the
parents didn't have anything to do with
it so it took them that long to do that
it was like 32 years good job
uh but yeah so they finally did that
now
uh she did actually
i mean to the australian government's
credit
as soon as that [ __ ] came out that they
found the jacket
and all of that
pretty much a week later they let her
out of prison they were like okay
okay
and they let her out so she got out
but again once she got out
um
she's still getting [ __ ] from like about
half the population nowadays who still
think that she did it she wrote a book
about it uh they made a movie i believe
it was in 1988
in australia new zealand it's known as
evil angels which was based on the book
that was written about it um and she
wrote a book about her own experiences
as well
in this country pretty much everywhere
else it's known as a cry in the dark
uh meryl streep is in it and she got in
academy award nomination and i kind of
feel like that was where everybody got
the the dingo ate my baby uh thing
because she does kind of say something
like that in the movie so i kind of feel
like that's when the meme came from i
think it was 1988 1980 1989 something
like that but yeah so you didn't make a
movie about it it's a good movie if you
haven't seen it i saw it a while back
but so there was that
and uh so yeah but it took until 2012
with a before they actually said
uh you know yes it was death by
dingo and it wasn't like open or
misadventure or whatever the hell before
that
now uh she was waiting she wrote a book
uh about her experiences
she did actually get some
compensation from the government
it was 1.3 million which sounds like a
lot
oh look at that baby
look at that baby she's like stop it
stop it that one
oh pookie pookie love you all right yeah
she got 1.3 million which sounds like a
lot
until you realize
1.3 million dollars
was less than a third
of their legal costs
so
it just went right down the memory hole
so it's it wasn't like a big [ __ ]
payday or nothing like that she got 1.3
million dollars just like well
that was that's like a fraction of what
i owe the lawyers so thanks for that
um but you know
uh now michael
the husband uh the two of them actually
divorced in 1991 i believe
um
you know kind of after they were both
exonerated
and
she remarried about a year later she
married an american publisher but they
moved back to australia like i said i'm
not judging if i was her i'd probably
like move out of australia because
i kind of feel like everybody's like
gonna you know spit on her like i said
but you know she wanted to live there
and that's her uh prerogative
so she still lives in australia as far
as i know to this day
uh her michael divorced in 1991 he died
in
2017 of leukemia
so the dad is dead
um he only did
like i said i think he only did 18
months in prison i don't even know he if
he did the whole sentence he got a
suspended sentence so he might not have
done any time [ __ ] australia well
because like i said the judge
i don't know i don't know if i want to
go here but i do kind of feel like
when something like this happens
particularly to a child
they're going to be harder
on the mom
than they are on the dad
i mean
i kind of feel like
i don't know i kind of feel like that's
the thing and we've talked about that
like when we talked about like serial
killers and stuff like that too the
weird thing about serial killers not all
of them but like a certain segment of
them
even if their dads
for example like physically abuse them
they tend to blame
their moms
for not preventing it rather than
blaming the dads for actually doing it
so they'll like take their rage out on
other women
because oh my mom didn't
keep me from getting abused but they
don't take it out on other men
even though their dads are the ones that
actually did the [ __ ]
which is very interesting to me that's
very interesting because they can't beat
their dad up well yeah that's exactly
why um because they see their they see
women
their dad is it's weaker yeah so it's
like well i can't beat my dad up he's
the one that's actually doing it so i'm
gonna like you know kind of take my
anger
and aim it toward
and i kind of feel like there's like a
societal expectation that it's like
women should be better than that yeah so
if you're not better if you're
allowing something that shouldn't be
allowed
then
that's your fault
you should have stopped
this evil man from doing whatever the
[ __ ] he was doing so i kind of feel like
that's a thing too
what's matter tell them all these gays
in there talk about my crack stop
talking about my crack that's not crack
that's just a shadow on my back man
look at that that is totally your ass
that's not crazy now you got hurt you
got jenny brainwashed about it there's
no crack in there
what are you cracking i'm [ __ ]
petting the cat don't gaslight but that
is totally your ass crap absolutely not
yes yes
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
look
don't gaslight me that is your ass crack
look honestly you were in here earlier
before you had those pants on
you had your shorts on give a [ __ ]
what'd you [ __ ] say you had your
shorts on that you wear around the house
yeah
and you're doing some [ __ ] like you were
putting that uh dvd case or that blu-ray
case together and stuff like look at
that ass crack see she's talking [ __ ]
she [ __ ] see she you got her telling
stories already
look it's not story your ass crack just
hangs out like all the time
i thought you were okay with it i don't
really understand why you're getting
upset
look once this show's over i thought you
were okay about it once this show's over
when we heat some carnitas up i'm gonna
make it i'll make a wet burrito
cheryl says it's totally time it is
i don't really understand why he tries
to convince me if it's not because
everybody that's your butt crack i've
seen
i've seen your butt crack
i've known you for more than for 10 11
12 years i know what your butt crack
looks like
that's your bike rack you guessed his
makeup and you walk around with your
butt crack showing i thought you were
proud of it
i didn't really understand why you're
shaving no i'm just trying i'm just
trying to finish this stuff i'm trying
to we got it on a tape top so okay
okay i mean [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
i'm just trying to put on a show
well not that kind of show
a donkey show
a butt crash show
well i don't know i got pookie over here
[ __ ] cheryl says tommy's a plumber
yeah i mean either
okay
all right honestly
should i tell this story i don't give a
[ __ ]
okay well you said it
we were in dollar general the other day
yeah you were buying like 60 worth of
sodas and cookies
yeah yeah and when you were going to do
the self checkout yeah and you just had
your shorts on yeah i thought to myself
wow look at that butt crack sticking out
i wonder if he knows that his butt crack
is sticking out does he care probably
not no right now i thought to myself
right now and i'm not i wasn't drunk i
was totally sober i was at dollar
general it was like the middle of the
afternoon and i was like huh they just
kind of slide down a little bit i don't
care like correct yeah that's what i'm
saying well see that's what i'm saying i
thought you didn't care
so the fact that you're now getting all
upset about it
is very confusing i'm sagging i'm
redness
i thought you really did not care if
your butt crack was hanging out because
your butt crack is honestly hanging out
a lot of the time
a lot of the time get that [ __ ] you get
a photograph photograph of that [ __ ]
you'd be mad if i did that
i could get so many photographs with so
many videos of your butt crack hanging
out
and i'd be like can i post this on
facebook no i'm not i'm absolutely not
allowed
taylor says he's doing it on purpose
y'all
i kind of feel well that's what i
thought too i thought he was too that's
why i'm i'm kind of like confused why
he's upset about it
sheila says jenny i thought you
[Laughter]
i mean the way he reacted to it
i thought he was like yeah that's my
butt crack whatever okay that's kind of
like the way he came at it
it's the dollar
buck [ __ ] you [ __ ] you were a dollar
general yeah
shopping
doing the self checkout
i was with you
we were buying 60 again you were buying
60 worth of soda and cookies and
whatever it got mad that i bought sixty
dollars worth so i wasn't mad i was just
i was like well look at that price and
then when you were doing that i was like
look at that ass crack i said i wonder
if that camera
this is how i think of things i said i
wonder if sat on camera and i wonder if
he would have been mad about the butt
crack because i was like wow i can't
believe how much [ __ ] prices went up
prices went up on all kinds dollar
general's still cheap though it's still
cheap but [ __ ] that soda went way up
a six-pack a [ __ ] a 12-pack of cans
shouldn't be 15 bucks man that's [ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] is that
i don't i don't like soda so i don't
really care
i mean honestly it used to be like i
just drank water out of the towel you
should be like five bucks i'm a simple
girl that's like five bucks i drink
water out of the top and i drink this
[ __ ] price is this fancy ass french
vodka from yeah francis sam's yeah fancy
fresh vodka it's fancy fries okay is
this case done
i suppose okay because look
i'm gonna get something give us
something to eat are you really you
hungry yeah you wanna burrito
sure all right all right
shut it down
it's almost nine
so we did do a good job with the uh tina
says do they have thongs at the dollar
general that's a good question you know
what probably they probably do i bought
i'm not gonna lie i bought a couple pair
of yoga pants there
i bought a couple pair because their
yoga pants are five dollars they got
curtains there they got [ __ ] wasted
they got everything they got waste
baskets you never know what you're gonna
see there you go down the aisle i went
there the other day
and i spent
legit
136
yeah i bought
uh
what did i buy oh i bought like tables i
bought like a little [ __ ] shelfy
thing i bought like some [ __ ] paper
to go on the back of my bookshelves i
bought some storage [ __ ] i bought all
kind of stuff i bought like some paint
136
i bought like some coffee [ __ ] too but
they have honestly i was like kind of
shocked dollar general
well they're one of those stores they
always open
in uh what they call food deserts where
it's like a rural area and there's no
food desert yeah it's like there's no
big grocery stores i mean we have a
publix like a mile away that wasn't
there at the time but before we didn't
have that so the dollar general is like
it's not next door to our house but it's
next door pretty much neighborhood like
i could walk to it if i had to it's it's
very very close
and i was actually shocked when i walked
in it's like all the [ __ ] that they have
because they not only have like a bunch
of uh you know kind of pantry food like
pantry staples canned goods like sugar
[ __ ] like that they have like some
refrigerated [ __ ]
but they also have like a bunch of
housewares yeah they have like frying
pans
coffee pots you never know what's going
to be bathroom rugs yeah all kind of
crazy [ __ ] like shower curtains you're
like oh wait hold on this is in here
and it's not it's i was small yeah so i
go there's all kind of i was going down
there the other day and [ __ ] went
through the damn toy aisle where the
toys were and i said and i was just
thinking to myself i wonder if they got
any star wars toys in here they didn't
but you know what they had
they had [ __ ] halo toys remember the
video game yeah they had little action
figures okay i never looked in the toy
section yeah i was like damn they got
these here and i was like that looked
good on the mantel and i was going i
looked at the price every 18 bucks i was
like i can spend that much for well i
like that
but honestly though i went the other day
and i was just kind of like look i was
looking for some shelving and storage
situations
as cheaply as i could get them and they
had a [ __ ] man i bought like a little
[ __ ] rug i bought like a little black
uh you know just kind of area rug ten
bucks tina's talking about the dollar
store eight bucks it is not it is not
the dollar store
yeah not okay
dollar tree yeah um and we have dollars
everything's a dollar
dollar general is a general is a general
story not everything's a dollar but
everything's cheaper than at places yeah
uh you know otherwise they do have like
[ __ ] name brands dollar general it's
not a buck though dollar general has
nothing to do with the dollar bill the
guy who made it was named his last name
was dollar that's my understanding
that's how it was it's two different
tila said do they have cat toys they do
yeah
you gotta watch because they don't have
i went there looking for the meat sticks
and they didn't have those but they did
have temptations yeah and they do have
some like
i mean they don't have it's kind of like
fresh milk eggs yeah cold cuts cheese
cheese [ __ ] like that uh frozen stuff
frozen pies frozen pizzas
uh and then you go to then they have
their own brand and they got cook
everything is a like a dollar dollar
fifty cookies everything's cheap
everything's not a buck but
like three dollars everything's cheaper
than you get a thing of parmesan cheese
that big for three dollars and it's
craft
some of it is their own store brand but
their own store brad's okay just don't
get the orange juice the orange juice
wasn't any good
and then they got their own potato chips
for a dollar big old bag of potato chips
kettle chips [ __ ] ruffles looking
[ __ ] but that's that's their branch
yeah just honestly though i was shocked
at like the housewares [ __ ] that they
had like just in terms of like big
bathroom stuff
pillows rugs they got makeup
yeah it's like i get like lipstick in
there yeah and like i said you can get
like decent lipstick in there for like a
dollar for two dollars which
is better than like the [ __ ] 38
dollars i was paying for this [ __ ]
before
yeah you know what i mean uh i get nail
polish in there dollar
you know so
and a lot of the like good makeup that i
would get at like walgreens it was like
eight or nine dollars
in dollar general it's like two three
bucks for the same thing yeah yeah well
they keep saying the dollar store it is
not a dollar store there's we have a
dollar store
it is not that
well like i said dollar okay it's the
dollar tree yeah is i think the one that
people are thinking about which we have
those two
dollar tree
everything that's in there every single
item is a dollar right those are awesome
too
this is dollar general
which
is a general store they kind of have
everything it's kind of like walmart but
in miniature yeah but it's cheaper than
walmart but honestly they have like
stuff that i didn't they're very small
yeah but when i went in there are you
going like that i went in there and i
was just like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] they
have like [ __ ] like i said they have
like [ __ ] rugs and pillows and like
they have like nice [ __ ] in there yeah
and it's like really not that expensive
i bought
um
a rug like a little like area rug it was
like eight bucks like for a big like
black rug
i bought this nice like lamp which looks
like an edison kind of like old school
that was like [ __ ] six or eight
dollars yeah i bought like a bunch of
like [ __ ] tables and shelving and
[ __ ] like that super super cheap uh also
they have like frames
which
are very expensive yes they're assumed
at dollar tree yeah it's not dollar tree
yeah it's a different yeah
it's a whole different language
it's a different shape and you know
there's stuff up in there up to 50 60
bucks
you know
but that's they're like the real
high-end ship like i said there's toys
in there for 20 each so what it is it's
it's um i think a lot of it is stuff
that's on clearance stuff that they
bought from other merch but it's
high-end stuff it's just that they're
trying to get rid of that's what i mean
it's decent [ __ ] it's stupid it's it's
and it's brand name [ __ ] yes largely
yeah um they do have like brand names
because like i said they go
they have like a whole food section with
like canned food and like box food and
they have like brand name stuff and it's
way cheaper
than walmart at target
they don't have everything
um well it's a little bit
yeah but i mean if you're
like i said it's right there
and
it's always like worth looking in there
first like if you're looking for
something i'll show them what a dollar
general looks like yeah
like i said they open a lot in like food
deserts which i get
and
honestly the one that we have here
the refrigerated section is
to be honest kind of like usually half
empty they all look like that yeah
that's what ours looks like it looks
exactly right exactly exactly that's
what i would say they all look like that
and i'll show you what they look like in
the middle and that's what
this is what they look like inside
they look like that in the inside
they all look like that well they're
good to like kind of look in them
because you never know what they're
gonna you never know what's in there
right
so it's kind of like it's a it's a
surprise everything yeah
it just looked like that
because i never expect them to like have
anything good and then we're like oh my
god they got this
way more than i thought yeah they look
like that
like i said i went in there the other
day and spent like 136 dollars on like
household [ __ ]
i bought
like storage [ __ ] i bought like little
tables like furniture they have like
furniture kind of stuff
they have
bathroom like [ __ ] uh
you know shower curtains
they have regular curtains and curtain
rods they have household [ __ ]
although one stuff that they didn't have
let's talk about that
was that
i thought that they would have we needed
um
some filters for our air conditioning
up here
uh this house is two stories
and we have
it's like separate ac
downstairs and upstairs
the upstairs ac
was being a little squirrely it started
to freeze over it started free it froze
yeah uh is what it did so we had to turn
it off and like let it thawne out
and the filter was dirty omega says yeah
it looks like b m in uk
because okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're yeah they're they're cool
they have
everything yeah
you gotta like kind of like go through
it they look small from the outside but
you go in there and they have like
everything i was like shocked yeah
number seven says unless you live in
oklahoma
they're full of merchandise all over the
floor and boxes outside yeah that's
another thing that we did notice
they'll get delivered all kinds of [ __ ]
that they can't stock
they'll just say here take i guess
the people that work at the store
probably well they probably don't get
paid enough to like give a [ __ ] i don't
think that's what it is i get that i
think i think the the the the corporate
headquarters says look we bought all
this [ __ ] sell it and they just force it
onto the store
so they're like [ __ ] damn i don't
know how we're gonna sell this you'll
find stuff [ __ ] stacked up on the
floor but they're selling it cheap to
try to get rid of it
so i think a lot of it is closeout stuff
i mean these lot of stocks i mean you
gotta really look because they don't
look around one thing about at least the
dollar general where we live yeah they
don't uh organize [ __ ] super well yeah
because you'll have drinks you'll have
two liters in five different places
inside the dash store and it's because
they're all coming at different times
and they i think it i think it's trying
to stock the [ __ ] as casey
whatever they're just like that's it we
got to put this somewhere and it's just
because
it's not i think i think what it is is
that they're not replenishing stock as
it's being sold
headquarters is just forcing stock on
them
well it's a lower end it's a lower end
story brands right so they're just kind
of like look just sell this stuff we
don't care what you do with it right and
honestly
if you're going and yeah like i said i
don't go out that often i get a dollar
general once or twice a week
um
you just gotta like look around look
around and see what you can see because
they don't organize anything yeah um
[ __ ] you want could be
pretty much anywhere yeah they're
talking about missing in target and [ __ ]
targets all right we have targets here
they're real nice in the inside
a lot nicer than a walmart walmarts are
[ __ ] up um for whatever reason i can't
i don't know if it's the whole vibe
pretty nice i don't like walmart right
um and going targets are fine but i will
like seriously you have to really kind
of like and shop
shopping for food at walmart superstores
man there's certain things that you want
to get there like [ __ ] canned goods
or [ __ ] big crates of eggs you can do
well on it but man now you if you're in
florida you want to go to publix that's
the high-end store
and they got better brands
pay a little bit more but they're nice
in the inside and [ __ ] publix has the
best [ __ ] store brand ice cream
you'll ever have it's almost as good as
bluebell well publix brand stuff
it's gourmet gonna say
publix is
deli and bakery yeah
is [ __ ] really good [ __ ] yeah you can
have cuban sandwiches and make you big
roasted chickens and [ __ ] and it's uh
and we get birthday cakes from publix
bakery pretty much everywhere oh yeah
his birthday my birthday [ __ ]
birthday cakes [ __ ] with a little
damn they're getting lemons and
strawberry i have never had a bad cake
from there if you could put your name on
it and everything publix is [ __ ]
great and then like i said the ice cream
publix brand ice cream publix brand
stuff is better than name brand yeah
honestly i don't think i've ever had
publix brand their branded stuff which
is just branded publix yeah um
i don't think i've ever had anything
that was like worse than the name brand
no better usually honestly it's usually
better and it's usually cheaper yeah um
so i will say the publix
they're uh
you know and maybe somebody could like
tell me different but everything that i
bought that was publix brand
was just as good or better
as the name brand style yeah gonna say
that's what a publix looks like and i
know everybody doesn't have those they
all look about that's a southern thing
yeah that's a southern thing
gonna say they got the best [ __ ] sub
sandwiches yeah and you get them there
at that deli oh my god the public's
daily they're all looking like man and
things are so good
honestly my favorite is their roast beef
on the multigrain with all the veggies
on it yeah
the one up up the street from ours is
one of these it has that kind of roof
and stuff it looks like that yeah yeah
yeah also they do like a thanksgiving
sub yeah
and then like they're produced stuff it
all looks like this
but they're they're real good
but like i said i
i don't think they have publix otherwise
no that's like a southern thing right
yeah
so in a lot of it's florida
yeah yeah that that's that's a good one
and we have one when like um maybe it's
a mile away by the
yeah maybe
uh taylor says we need publix on the
west coast yeah yeah
i mean
yeah tila says i'm not a fan of walmart
honestly if i can avoid going to walmart
yeah
man
walmart has like a vibe
and i'm not like really into that every
time we have to like go to walmart i'm
like oh
i don't know what it is i'll get a
dollar general all day long i will go to
big lots all day long but walmart has
like a weird
i don't know man i don't know what it is
most of them just look like that in the
produce section
okay like i said i mean publix
everybody in the south
knows that those [ __ ] do the best
subs
best ice cream
best ice cream that's roasted chickens i
mean they're roasted their fried chicken
is pretty awesome too yeah
sometimes they're delicious
salty sometimes fantastic yeah
they're bakery
fantastic yeah i've gotten so many cakes
from their bakery yeah and they're all
[ __ ]
heavenly yeah
i mean
their bakery is just [ __ ] off the
chain yeah cheese says i've always heard
about good things about pumpkins they're
fried chicken piece rare but yeah it's
good off the chicken the the the only
problem is every now and then depending
on what the staff is like the chicken
the fried chicken is a little bit too
salty
it depends on who they got working in
there i've had that but
you're not going to play their subs for
about five or six dollars you could get
a sub that big that thick and cold cut
meat so with any kind of meat any kind
of
cheese you want on it and they'll put it
unlimited toppings just everything the
sweet [ __ ] pickles the cucumber
pickles what do they call it what was
that the garlic pickles yeah garlic
pickles [ __ ]
uh uh jalapenos
uh
oily
dressing on it five different kinds of
bread that multigrain bread is [ __ ]
great multi-grains maybe multi-grain
yeah and
you can get like a half a [ __ ]
sub that's about that big for about four
dollars five dollars you can get the
full one for only a couple dollars more
so you just get the big one
you know well you can save it because i
eat half and then i'll eat half of it
for lunch that they give it to you and
they cut it in half you know what i mean
it's just and you know i've been all
over boston and new york and [ __ ] and
no man [ __ ] publix would beat a
boston deli i mean they're so
[ __ ] really good are so [ __ ] good
their subs are so cool yeah the south
has got [ __ ] really good food
yeah if you know where to look if you
know where to look yeah if you're from
new york we got new yorkers to come here
they go oh man the pizza yeah you're not
going to find good pizza well you you
have to know where to look you have to
make
your own pizza yeah [ __ ] great i'll
concede yeah we don't have great pizza
down here the pizza here's corporate
pizza it's gonna be pizza if you want
really good if you're from new york you
want really good pizza you've got to
make your own that's right and if you're
a champion if you're that much of a
[ __ ] man and you're italian that
you're worried about
make your own [ __ ] pizza and you can
do it get you a stone and you get you
some bread flour you learn how to make
it you know real guido should know how
to make pizza i'm [ __ ] an irish and i
know how to make pizza make pizza better
than
i [ __ ] i i've had new york pizza
[ __ ] chicago pizza [ __ ] detroit
pizza
uh they all have their own things you
know what i mean i [ __ ] i really love
it i rag on [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with yankees a lot but they the
but yankees do have some good [ __ ] they
got good yankees
but um
and not all pizzas the same and
everything i know you all want to fight
over the [ __ ] pizza
honestly all pizza is delicious yeah
even gonna i'll take any pizza you got
yeah i don't really care yeah that
detroit square pizza is good
cooking steal it's all right
uh [ __ ]
a new york [ __ ] kind of thin slice
pizza is pretty good too the chicago
deep dish especially the upside down
chicago deep dish with the sauce on the
top that can that can be good too it all
depends on who's making this [ __ ] and
what the components are
there's a bunch of different
interpretations of it but if you're that
serious about it in the world i can't
leave you because the pizza then [ __ ]
you need to be learning how to make
pizza then make your own make your own
[ __ ] if you're that serious shut the
[ __ ] up and learn how to make pizza then
you'll be able to make pizza wherever
you go
get up be a man well you think the
[ __ ] mongols and you you think they
in the huns traveled all across europe
[ __ ] killing and stealing and raping
and pillaging and asking their mom to
make them a pizza making i'm hungry no
they may they cook for themselves they
cook for themselves learn how to cook
learn how to [ __ ] cook then you then
you then you're not you're untethered
then you can go anywhere
i kind of feel like that probably is a
good skill yeah oh yeah
hell yeah at least know how to make like
a handful of learn how to make good
dishes things that you have to have that
you like yeah then you have to learn how
to make them if you're super into pizza
yeah learn how to make pizza i'm into
pizza because if you move somewhere that
doesn't have good pizza because i'm
gonna say yeah central florida
corporate pizza they have corp they
evidently had goodness not gray pizza
evidently they had good pizzerias here
in the 80s and the 70s and there were
people from new york who moved here but
they changed it yeah but they did not
survive against the corporations over
time
but they were mom pop places look i'm
not going to [ __ ] on like the corporate
like in a pinch i will eat
pizza hut papa john's dominance i'm not
going to like [ __ ] it's fine
uh your pizza is better we'll see you t
checking out see you t
your pizza is better yeah mom and pop
pizza is better yeah but
you know so i'm not going to like and
also i'm not going to [ __ ] on
northerners to come in here be like you
guys don't have any good pizza i'm like
i agree yeah i don't think we
there's not a lot of places to have a
good pizza but if you uh you should
probably like make your own pizza then
because you're not gonna find any good
pizza around here yeah
other than you're just gonna find
delivery yeah delivery stuff which like
i said if you're willing to like i'll
eat it it's fine
i don't mind it
um
but like i said your pizza is like
a hundred times better than there is
that's because i went after more new
york style [ __ ] recipes yeah i mean
your [ __ ] is like you kind of want to
use lombardi's as as a [ __ ] as as the
template to go for
for old lombardi's i heard lombardi's
has been slacking in recent decades in
new york
but you kind of want to go kind of what
lombardi's was doing but you know you
you want to understand [ __ ] deep dish
and chicago deep dish on in cast iron
you want to know you want to know them
all you because pizza has a whole world
there's a whole world of pizza
you know
depending on what kind of flour you can
get or can't get you know what i mean
like you can't make a thin crust pizza
with [ __ ]
general general purpose flour
you know you need bread flour for that
if you only if you're restricted to
[ __ ]
general purpose flour you're going to
have to go with some kind of thick crust
pizza something that's airy and light
something like a something like a
detroit but you can still do something
still do it right like a detroiter you
can do a chicago style that's what i'm
saying it's like well that's the cool
thing about pizza matter where you are
sure that's the cool thing about pizza
it's like it's versatile it is a guido
science but you have to know like where
you come from what can you get you have
to understand as far as like flowers as
far as toppings as far as like what can
we do with this exactly
and that's what you gotta like work with
you gotta be you gotta understand guinea
thinking
all right
[ __ ] i say that with much respect you
[ __ ] you you can make pizza and
[ __ ] uh look i don't know how chinese
i make pasta
i don't eat pasta i make pasta you don't
have flour and eggs i bought you a pasta
so i can do that too for your birthday
or for christmas oh there's nothing like
fresh pasta i mean fresh pasta i need we
need to get back in that i'm going to
get back into making the pasta you
should because that's like one of my
favorites so much weight it just puts so
much fat on you that's okay yeah
i'm trying to lose this fat
but you know i'm trying to get pretty
and yet you're still making pizza though
it's not as bad as pasta
pasta's worse uh
pasta's worse carbs are carbs yeah yeah
but there's more of them in that [ __ ]
plate of paper yeah there's more
you buy weight yeah
because you give you give me fresh pasta
i will eat the [ __ ] out of that oh yeah
it's addictive i'll eat a whole [ __ ]
salad bowl i'll eat a whole mixing bowl
of pasta that's how much i love that
[ __ ] yeah well i probably could i
probably would too i gotta be real
[ __ ] careful
seductive very seductive
italians understood it they understood
it of course yeah hell yeah
it's a ultimate poor people food when
you're starving i gotta say that we're
not starving that bad you know honestly
though
yeah
if you would think that if pasta made
you fat yeah everybody in italy would be
fat and they're not well they don't eat
that much of it i don't think they do a
lot of [ __ ] dancing i don't think
they eat a whole lot they drink a lot of
red wine
they got fat people there
but a lot of the women yeah but not as
many facts people don't realize how much
seafood italians eat and a lot of fresh
[ __ ]
vegetables a lot of fresh
lettuce and stuff it's not that heavy in
it
look we gotta go we gotta go you think
yeah because uh [ __ ] we got people
checking out and uh i gotta make
something to eat don't you want somebody
yeah okay make something alright people
i'm gonna let cheney check out i'm gonna
start
getting food ready rebecca just showed
up i'm hungry who who showed up rebecca
just showed up sorry i'm late no you're
right you're yeah i grew up listening to
this case as it happened lindy
chamberlain went through hell crucified
by media
yeah
yeah
uh yeah i'm gonna say we've been on for
how has it been okay more than four
hours
um i'm gonna say right now rebecca
okay this was some [ __ ]
this
poor [ __ ] family
their baby
got dragged off by a wild dog
and eaten like a [ __ ]
canopy
and
then
that wasn't bad enough but they got
[ __ ]
vilified in the media
and later through the courts
that they had [ __ ] done that [ __ ]
somehow uh it was like their
they were in a cult and it but
they sacrificed the baby or something i
don't really know
so it was that
and
i don't even i don't know i can't
imagine how that
[ __ ]
affected them
but
man liddy chamberlain she's still alive
uh her husband michael died back in 2017
of
key man
but she's still alive she remarried
she's still living in australia i don't
know why she would but okay
um
yeah she still lives there
and
uh
yeah so
apparently to this day according to some
people that we had in the chat
people in australia still to this day uh
still spit it through spit at her in the
street thinking that she killed her baby
which
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
up
but yeah
um
she didn't
come on
like a wild dog ate the baby
that's what wild animals do come on
so
that happened and then she
had her whole entire life ruined because
of it
but
you know
there was that so
hopefully
we'll see
all right she's a ballsy lady because
she's had to be i mean
i can't imagine
honestly
i don't know i piss and moan about
myself all the time but it's just kind
of like i can't imagine what it would
have been like
to lose
a baby and like i said a daughter that
she had desperately wanted because she'd
had a couple babies prior they were with
boys but she'd really wanted like a
little girl and she had one
nine weeks after the girl was born
a wild dog
ate her
and then
that sucked enough and then later
everybody said oh well you did it
you're in a weird cult and you
sacrificed her like you slit her throat
and
covered it up and then she went to
prison
she went to [ __ ] prison can you like
imagine what that must have been like
i don't know this is like this case like
really [ __ ] me up and i watched a live
like i knew about this before because i
saw the movie but
i don't know i watched a lot of
documentaries about this and it really
[ __ ] me up because i was kind of like
thinking
what how would i have like reacted if
this had been me
if this had been me if i had had a baby
and i was like super excited oh my god i
finally had like a little girl i always
wanted
and we went on a trip and then this
horrible accident happened
and then suddenly i was
vilified as like this satanic like
man
enemy number one and
like how would that have
felt and honestly still nowadays and the
fact that
a dingo ate my baby
became like a joke
because i kind of feel like that one
that was maybe more the movie's fault
than her fault
because they did make a movie called the
cry in the dark uh with meryl streep and
it was like nominated for an academy
award so a lot of people saw it
but
i can't imagine what that would feel
like so i can't imagine how i would feel
like
now you're like a pop culture
meme
where like oh it didn't go away and i
kind of feel like people say that and
that like they don't even know like what
it's referring to
i don't know
i don't know
i was thinking about a lot today i'm
like i knew about this guy i saw cry in
the dark like back in the old days and
it's like i knew about this case from
back in the old days i grew up in the
80s
so i remember hearing about this back
then but it's like
man like the more i think about it
nowadays i'm like the more [ __ ] up it
is and it's just like the more
people like make jokes about that
meme and it's like ah
i don't know it just upsets me the more
like i think about it but you know
um
yeah she had she didn't have another
baby while she was in prison i mean
i just i can't [ __ ] imagine what that
would be like and she's kind of like i
have to [ __ ]
i gotta give it to lindy man she is kind
of like not
letting this affect her
and i don't know if that's just her
being like man [ __ ] that i'm not gonna
let them like see me sweat
which maybe like i you know i get that
if i was her i would do that too
but
she's just kind of like i'm
not gonna when they let her out
allegedly i don't know if this is true
when they let her out
um
she said something like somebody like
the media asked her like oh how do you
feel like you're getting let out and she
said something like
very like sardonic and she was just kind
of like
well it's nice to be like exonerated for
some [ __ ] i didn't do like she said some
[ __ ] like that and i was kind of like
queen
i was like that's exactly what i would
have said but you know what i mean um
but the fact that she was able to keep
her [ __ ] together enough because i'd
have been like really mad if i was her
but
she kept that [ __ ] together and she was
just kind of like
yeah nice to be exaggerated for some
[ __ ] i didn't do
[ __ ] she was kind of like that and i
was kind of like
yeah
yeah
i like that i like that
but yeah but i do feel bad for her
though because honestly her whole
[ __ ] entire life is ruined and if it
was me
i would change my name
but i mean you shouldn't have to you
shouldn't have to
but
if it was me i probably would gonna say
uh yeah rebecca says they don't think
it's a real case
that this baby was killed by a dingo
honestly nowadays
i kind of feel like i'm happy in some
ways that a lot of time has passed and
that most of the people that probably
prosecuted this [ __ ] are dead um
and now everybody's like
what the [ __ ] obviously like the baby
got eaten by a dingo um
[ __ ] happens like i said
wild animals do eat babies
i live in florida
alligators eat little babies
all the time
i don't love it it's not cool but
they do it they don't know any better so
it does happen
so the fact that that happened in
australia and everybody was very very
quick to blame her
for being in a cult and sacrificing her
that says to me
that is more about the culture at the
time than it does about the case in
general
it just makes me sad that she had to
spend so many years in prison and have
her whole entire [ __ ] reputation
ruined because of this [ __ ] so
just gotta say thank you bryce
good episode oh thank you very much
thank you very much
uh [ __ ] and show good night to tonight
jenny thank you very much
uh rebecca says when i can i'll send you
something on the kidnap torture gang
rape and murder of australian nurse
anita kobe it's horrific yeah you should
because
for whatever reason i'm very fast like
i'm into like american crimes too but i
guess because i live here it's kind of
like yeah there's another one but i'm
really into like
uk crimes and i'm also really into like
australian crimes because i feel like
y'all don't have as many of them which
is good
but
we don't hear as much about them in the
us so i kind of feel like people don't
know as much about them so please like
send me some [ __ ]
um
but yeah so
at least like she got out of jail
she got 1.3 million dollars which
it sounds like a lot
it was less than a third of her legal
costs so that was probably like gone
immediately which is like really sad
uh she did remarry her uh cause like i
said her she had divorced from her
husband in 1981 he died in
2017. he died of cancer
and
so there was that
uh she's apparently been keeping a low
profile which like i said don't blame
her i would do the same
and uh so i'm not gonna like bother her
i don't you know she just wants to
[ __ ] live and that is cool with me
and i'm really sorry what happened to
her that really shouldn't have happened
her [ __ ] entire life is ruined
and that blows
but
you know so she remarried uh to an
american publisher who was also a
seventh-day adventist
and they both they moved to australia as
far as i know they still live there to
this day but like i said i'm not gonna
go any further into it because i don't
want anybody bothering them so there's
that kind of
thing too
but finally in 2012
they did get some
a little bit of closure
in the fact that the death certificate
for the baby
was
uh changed
from
kind of like unknown or like open
circumstances
to
killed by dingo so that was kind of like
a big deal
to them i mean they were kind of like
look it
at least that
removed like all
uh you know blame from them so they they
were kind of like uh gunning for that
and they finally got it 2012.
so
man this is like this is such a [ __ ]
bummer in case
i gotta say too
i wanted to bring this up this is on the
wikipedia page 2004
there was this dude
because it just goes to show that people
are
seriously not above cashing in on
anything
2004 this dude in melbourne named frank
cole
he comes forward and he says
oh my god
i shot a dingo in 1980
and it had a baby in its mouth
he comes forward and says um obviously
he just wants some [ __ ] attention
and uh so the cops did interview him
anyway like just in case and then after
a while they're like yeah this dude's
like full of [ __ ]
he said that he's like oh my god i have
like all these ribbons like from the
baby's jacket like to prove it even
though the mom was like yeah the jacket
didn't have any ribbons on it it was
just like a cardigan with like
it was white with like
yellow like trim on it but it didn't
have any ribbons like i never said that
so
he tried to like play that up and they
were just kind of like yeah no we're not
having that
so
he got kind of like [ __ ] i don't
think he got like persecuted or any
prosecutor or anything but
there's that so nice try
um
also
2005 again
a 25 year old woman
named aaron
horosberg
she said
that she was
azaria chamberlain like i'm the baby but
i didn't like the dingo didn't kill me
and i'm grown up now
and she tried to like
parlay that into like some fame or
fortune or whatever and at which case
even the media and the authorities were
like
no
so that didn't happen
try you're on the wikipedia page
you know so that's something but uh
nobody else believed her so yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] up that you would do who
the [ __ ] would do that
i don't understand these people without
[ __ ]
scribbles that would do this kind of i
wish i didn't have any scruples i'd
probably be richer than i am right now
but
i can't do this kind of stuff man it's
like it's cold-blooded that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up don't do that
you say you're like a dead baby
[ __ ] off with that yeah so she did that
nobody believed her good piss off
uh so like i said
michael the dad uh he died in 19
or in 2017 rather he was 72 and he died
of cancer
um
but the mom lindy is still alive
and uh so please leave her alone because
i'm sure she has enough problems
ah that i don't know this case like
bummed me out like reading about gotta
say [ __ ] dead babies
wild animals eating babies that's like
not like i said i
i don't want to be eaten by an animal
that's like one of my worst [ __ ]
nightmares
so
i'm sure the baby probably didn't suffer
all that much but
that doesn't make me feel any better in
light of what happened subsequently
so even the mom totally did
so
i don't know it just doesn't make it
better to me um you know so
we're gonna do that all right so
tom took off to cook a long time ago
honestly i guess this [ __ ] worked
because this [ __ ]
stream
it held up like pretty much all night i
had a couple of like [ __ ]
i had a couple hiccups where i went to
red
but very very okay
that's good
i was worried
but the [ __ ] stream hold out held up
so i'm very very excited about it
uh so yeah
thank you everybody for hanging in with
us for more than four hours
yellow troopers
uh
what are we gonna talk about okay so
friday night
we're gonna do our sidetrack show
it'll be fun i don't know what we're
talking about but we'll figure something
out
and uh yeah so hopefully everybody
enjoyed this show this evening
and we will see you guys on friday
evening at 5 p.m
eastern standard time
and
thank you very much for joining us
and goodbye